foreign
all right you are all set to go Madam
chair
thank you very much
good morning everyone
we are going to open the hearing on
House Bill 541 and I would ask the prime
sponsor representative Betty gay
to go ahead and introduce our bill oh
pardon me Madam chair could you please
read the 91a script and do a roll call
I was just like anxious to get right to
work
sorry I'm so discombobulated this
morning please forgive me everyone
okay
as as chair of the children and family
law committee I find that due to the
state of emergency declared by the
governor as a result of the covid-19
pandemic and in accordance with house
rule 67 and the governor's emergency
order number 12.
pursuant to executive order 2020-04 this
public body is authorized to meet
electronically this is a public hearing
on bills referred to the committee an
executive session may follow please note
that there is no physical location for
members of the public to observe and
listen contemporaneously to this meeting
however in accordance with the emergency
order I am confirming that all members
of the committee and select legislative
staff have the ability to commune
communicate contemporaneously during
this meeting through the zoom electronic
meeting platform and the public has
access to contemporaneously listen and
if necessary participate in this meeting
by the zoom platform or by telephone all
necessary accessed information
has been made available in the house
calendar and through the electronic
calendar on the general report website
the notice for this meeting complies
with house rules and RSA 91a anyone who
has a problem accessing the meeting
should call
271-3600 or email HCS leg.state.nh.us
in the event the public is unable to
access the meeting the meeting will be
adjourned and rescheduled Christina Dyer
is the staff assisting us please note
that all votes that are taken during
this meeting shall be done by roll call
vote let's start the meeting by taking a
roll call attendance when each member
states they're present please also
Escape whether there is
[Music]
first
anyone in the room with you during this
meeting which is required under the
right to know law Madam Clark
e
that's okay that's my maiden name
representative rice would you please
tell me what the LLB room number is
we are in
201 and 203.
thank you
representative DeSimone yeah
at the OB
representative yokella
present I'm at home alone
representative lewicki
I am president at the LLB
representative Bellinger
Belanger I'm sorry present at the LOB
representative cross
president
representative Litchfield
I am present
um I am remote and I am in the room
alone but I do have my husband and two
of my children here that may be in and
out
thank you representative Smith
I am
um home and I'm alone
position
representative long
[Music]
I am here in my house alone
representative Ali Sayer here with my
new puppy
representative Grossman
good morning I am here at my home office
in Exeter and my husband is in the house
as well message after the tell
representative Levick
I am here at my home in my kitchen alone
representative wayfar
Wakefield
thank you good morning I am home with my
husband and three children will be
joining me sometime
it will appear here
representative Petrino
it's going to be late he already emailed
me
okay
Madam chair if they can let myself or
Christina know what time they enter for
the record
when they do come in late definitely
thank you
representative holtshuler
good morning I'm here in my office in
strata Malone
thank you
thank you madam chair and I am here in
the LOB
foreign
and we will start with representative
Betty gay
thank you madam chair and thank you
children and family law I'll just do a
sound check first can you hear me well
yes we can hear you great and I did
dress up I didn't realize
well it makes me feel better so
um my bill is House Bill 541 relative to
the priority of child support payments
over other court costs and expenses as
we as I keep learning about Family Court
there are lots of different kinds of
expenses
so the text it really speaks for itself
in any proceeding to enforce the payment
of Child Support which would bring up
the thought of somebody claiming that
they no longer can afford their child
support so they would come to court or
be asked to come to court when they
didn't pay uh so in anything proceeding
to enforce the payment both parents
shall submit a financial affidavit
regarding income from all sources
including those used to pay all costs
either assessed by the court or
optionally associated with the preceding
such as but not limited to fees for
Guardian Ad Litem visitation centers and
legal representation
and the payment shall have priority over
the payment of all other costs assessed
by the court
payment of Child Support shall have
priority over the payment of all other
costs assessed by the court are
associated there is uh from from the sad
stories that I've learned and I'm sure
you've heard many more than I have on
this committee
child support is critical
and unfortunately it doesn't come first
and when children grow up in poverty
they they do not thrive
and the um
it doesn't sound like this is
supposition because I don't have any
proof of it but it sounds like the state
does not have a lot of money to spend on
financial
um
let's see there's a special word for it
but it means digging into somebody's
finances so we're pretty much left to uh
uh trust what the parents
display
and my concern is that there are lots of
kids not getting child support who then
are being supported
uh on the not so wonderful amount of
money that our welfare can provide
so this is
my main concern is the children
but as taxpayers we could also be
concerned that some parents are not
paying and uh putting the burden on the
state
and it's not you know it would be hard
to maintain a home
uh based on the welfare payments and
again I'm using
old-fashioned terms because I'm sure
there's a better term than to say
welfare but State support which of
course is critical when a for a child to
have some kind of support
um so that's really my whole concern is
is the children and the fact that they
all don't always get child support from
parents who can't afford it but don't
have to prove it and it's not easily not
easily proven
so I would like it to be a requirement
that they show where they're getting the
money to go to court to pay their uh
other assessed because they may not be
showing that we know for sure they don't
always show it and my information comes
from people who have worked for a safe
place and Haven for many years
so with that I'll just open myself to
any questions should you have some
thank you representative gay
um I have a question so in this bill
um you're stating that
their their child support shall have
priority over payment of all other costs
and expenses so does that include their
attorney are we going to be denying
people due process and the right to have
an attorney represent them
and and I parenting plan case
that's not denying people
to have representation
the usually the situation that I'm
concerned about is when one parent has
representation because they can afford
it and the other parent does not this is
an attempt to level the playing field so
that both parents both parents have to
have to ex let's see what's the right
word disclose the money that they're
using in court so that would include
attorney fees that's not to stop anybody
from having representation it's just to
show both parents
on an equal unequal footing
thank you and I paid by the way I paid
child support for a few years for my son
so I'm not speaking from oh this is a
certain sex
uh oriented I I completely understand
where you're coming from I am still
currently till this day owed seventy
thousand dollars in child support so I I
completely understand where you're
coming from but I would never deny my
children's father
um
the right to have an attorney I'm not
this bill does not deny anybody from
having an attorney no way does it deny
it it's just saying that if you're
spending
however much on an attorney
you need to disclose where that money
came from you have a rich Uncle who's
giving you the money and saying oh here
I'll give you it but when somebody is
self-employed they don't always have to
disclose their income and yet uh the
saddest stories I've heard from a person
who supported people going to court who
are victims of domestic abuse but this
would apply to anybody
um
to have a person file and say I'm too
poor to pay this child support them
that's been assessed to me but they're
being represented by a very famous
attorney and everybody knows how
expensive they are
okay thank you a representative long
thank you madam chair uh thank you
representative gray so just for Clarity
on my own Clarity uh the proceedings to
enforce child support payment so if
if I'm bringing my spouse because of
failure to pay child support and I have
an attorney I'm still going to claim
that however I still get to keep my
attorney because I'm not the one I'm not
the one that has a child support issue
however if I'm the one going to court
because I failed to pay child support
and I owe two thousand dollars but my my
uh disclosure shows that I paid five
thousand dollars
you're saying the judge will look at
that and say you're going to take 2 000
out of that five and give it to your
child so you're not really saying no you
can't get a lawyer uh but you are saying
priority is child support over my five
thousand dollars for the lawyer is that
correct
thank you representative you have really
succinctly stated the situation yes
representative Belanger
thank you madam chair representative gay
when in your bill it states a parent
shall submit a financial affidavit
are you are you aware if they're already
filling out that financial affidavit
prior to attending a child support
hearing
is it my turn
yep he asked you the question okay
um I think that a fine a financial
affidavit is standard standard for the
course uh what is not what was explained
to me a couple of years ago is that you
don't necessarily have to put down how
is anybody going to know
if you are receiving if you are uh have
more income than you're showing
um
it's just a giveaway when you show up in
court and say
I can't pay this I'm too poor but you
have representation that everybody knows
cost
oh easily a thousand dollars
so that's the the point here I'm uh
trying to make it broad enough that the
situation you think of would fit
so could you narrow this clarify it a
little bit more
follow us
thank you
um
so my concern would be
I guess if
the question yeah I'm just trying to
formulate it so if the parent who is
trying if the parent was trying to fight
the child support
because they are splitting custody
does this would this preclude them from
having to
pay for pay for child support while this
is still in limbo
that's a technical legal question that I
do not
do not know I'm just pointing out the
goal
that if somebody can afford
um all these other court fees including
including but not limited to an attorney
they can pay all these others but they
can't pay child support that that says
that's that's a problem the child
support should come first
representative alsheller
you've got to unmute
representative you're muted
she can't unmute
there we go I couldn't unmute I don't
know what was going on there
um thank you very much good morning
everybody
um thank you representative gay for the
question uh just
wanted to know if um the New Hampshire
administrative Justice of the circuit
court has reviewed this and what their
opinion is and what they've um
what they've told you about
how this would work
I have not received any I did not ask I
didn't know who who I would be showing
it to but I also you know since this is
public
and I certainly get uh messages from
people who are concerned about the
subject of bills as we all get lots of
them uh no one has come no one has
contacted me to give an opinion uh and
I'd certainly be concerned about a
negative opinion
sure may follow up Madam chair
go ahead thank you
um so representative K my second ask is
is this um
is this bill based on the other states
are doing this do do we have an example
of other states that
um bump child support payments above
um the above legal fees
I am not aware of what other states do
uh however I know we're not the worst
um we're not the worst in our priorities
well there's something yeah yeah
my poor husband went through this in
Ohio and whereas we were concerned about
visitation rights they were so far
behind they were just concerned to make
sure people were paying their child
support so uh it didn't get more
sophisticated than that that we knew of
and of course he did he paid very
consistently
um
no it would be interesting but if
another state is not concerned about
this I don't mind being in the Forefront
and bringing it to the attention that
children's needs should come first
thank you uh representative Litchfield
did you have a question can you use the
raise the hand thing on there because I
won't always see you actually raising
your hand yes absolutely thank you thank
you madam chair and thank you
representative gay
um I feel as though this bill definitely
has the purest of intent
um I do know though as I've read through
it and pondered over it
um the past couple of days I have some
confusion
um and if I may ask two questions one
I'm just trying to understand if there
was an outsider helping to fund the
legal bills how is that relevant so if
the uncle steps in or the grandfather
steps in how is that relevant is my
first question
from a moral point of view
oh I'm not being polite I really do
appreciate all your questions I just get
nervous and forget the formality
um if if a person's
is being subsidized by someone else
that is income
and it should be declared
just because you have a rich Uncle who
says oh here's a few thousand dollars
because I don't want to see you quote
lose in court
that's income they ought to be concerned
about the kids if they've got enough
money to spend on attorney they've got
enough money to help support those
children that's my opinion and that's my
moral platform
so
um Madam chair may I follow up on that
and still ask the other question would
that be okay yep okay thank you
um so my question is I'm just trying to
I and again I understand where you're
coming from the pr 710 I'm trying to
understand
it is not the rich uncle's obligation to
pay child support it is not his child so
if someone is really in a position where
they are really truly unable to afford
exorbitant child support bills and there
is a family member or a friend that is
willing to step in and say I will help
you with these legal fees to make this
right
I feel as though we're looking to deny
that and that's just what I'm trying to
understand so please understand I'm not
trying to be combative I'm trying to
understand the situation where is your
question though my I guess my question
is
why would it be the responsibility of
the person funding the attorney for
example the uncle to pay child support
which I believe that representative gay
answered okay
um and then I can answer it again it's
not their obligation to pay but it is
income for the person who's not paying
okay
um and then
the follow-up
I do and if this is if this is not
if this is not specifically a question
please stop me
um again I'm just trying to wrap my head
around it I feel like it's um I feel
like it's kind of a vicious circle or
cycle if someone is continuing to go to
court because maybe they can't afford
the child support but yeah we're pulling
the attorney fees out ahead of time I
don't know I feel like it it sounds like
a circular cycle and again my question
is trying to understand right so
representative Litchfield I believe this
would be something for a work session
because it really isn't a direct
question for um the sponsor
um because I feel like you keep coming
back to the same question and I and I
understand what you're trying to get at
but I don't think we can get there
may I attempt one brief response
yes representative thank you very much I
promise this is it
I'm my goal is to level the playing
field
the questions were asked of me before
this is the second time I entered this
this uh subject
if a if one person says I can't pay
chances are the other person doesn't
have money
so if we're interested in being equal
and fair
the person who doesn't have money for an
attorney
is not being represented by by a rich
uncle
and if they are they ought to be able to
declare that too so the whole goal is to
make things equal and fair we can't make
their incomes equal but we can be fair
and treat them both equally
thank you very much for all your
questions
thank you very much
up next is
um Karen Hebert
um from the Department of Health and
Human Services and she asked for five
minutes
thank you madam chair
um I just wanted to First for
representative gay uh acknowledge that
her recognition of the importance of
Child Support is much appreciated
um otherwise uh
I had subsequently
moved to withdraw any testimony so I
will do that now thank you
okay
thank you very much
are there any questions for Karen Hebert
see none okay thank you very much up
next is
um
Aaron Jacina
a lobbyist with New Hampshire legal
assistance and she's asked for two
minutes to speak in opposition
can everyone hear me okay
yes thank you
thank you chairwoman rice and members of
the committee my name is Aaron Jacina
and I direct the domestic violence
advocacy project at New Hampshire legal
assistance
legal assistance provides civil legal
services to New Hampshire's poor our
services address the legal problems
affecting our clients daily survival and
most basically
for more than 20 years our domestic
violence advocacy project has been
representing victims and survivors of
domestic violence sexual assault and
stalking in their protective order cases
as well as in their highly validated
divorce and parenting cases
I'm here today to testify an opposition
of House Bill 541 I will note that I
testified in opposition to a near
identical Bill last session which was
House Bill 1193 which this committee
voted in expedient to legislate in a
unanimous 18-0 vote
I want to First address the issue of the
financial affidavits raised by
representative gay under Family Division
rule 2.16 in all cases in which support
is in any way involved each party is
required to file with the court in
exchange with the other party a
financial affidavit at least seven days
prior to any hearing
on that financial affidavit parties must
indicate all sources and amounts of
income and expenses so lines three
through six of this bill
apparently as this is already a required
Court practice
as to the issue of prioritizing child
support payments I think we can all
agree that paying child support is an
important obligation and non-payment of
Child Support should carry penalties but
what this bill does is create an access
to justice issue and an access to
service issue so I'm just going to give
you an example I hope this is will help
maybe clarify things so consider an
unmarried couple with two kids the dad
has been abusing mom for the duration of
their relationship dad had a decent job
during the relationship but right before
the petition he decides he doesn't like
that job anymore which was a relatively
high paying job and decides he's going
to take a minimum wage job
he uses the fact that Mom now works much
more than him and makes significantly
more than him so the kids should stay
with him the majority of the time and
mom should pay him child support
so Mom needs to hire a lawyer to help
the court see that he is now voluntarily
underemployed but she may not be able to
do that under this bill
so because Mom was unrepresented
um abusive dad gets parenting time that
may not be in the best interest of the
children and as a result mom the victim
becomes responsible for paying a child
support award when she should be
receiving child support
in addition this bill is asking to pit
support and contact between a parent and
child against one another child support
is important and contact between parent
and a child may be important it may be
that the contact can only happen at a
supervised visitation center that
requires a fee having to pick one or the
other seems like an impossible choice
for those parents
lastly the language in lines eight
through nine is vague and is likely to
lead to confusion the bill describes
that all other costs associated with the
proceedings
um that that those need to come
secondary to paying child support but
does that include payment of health
insurance does that include payment of a
mortgage or rent is unclear with the
language currently in this bill so I
thank you for your time I'm happy to
take any questions
um and that's all I have thank you
are there any questions for Miss Jacina
representative long
thank you thank you madam chair uh Mr
Cena
um so
currently on the uh like you said
between three and five is currently
happening so these um
these affidavits do they include a gift
I got from a family member
so that's a really good question I
appreciate the question thank you so
that absolutely absolutely should be
disclosed on a financial affidavit I
will also point out that the financial
affidavit is not the only document that
the parties have to exchange there is
something called mandatory disclosures
it's rule 1.25 a under Family Division
rules
um this was really meant to level the
playing field
um because when parties are represented
they often exchange Financial Discovery
it's called interrogatories but if
you're unrepresented you may not know to
do that so the court did level the
playing fields and said that all parties
have to comply with 1.25 a which is an
exchange of financial documents in
addition to the financial affidavit so
that would be bank statements mortgage
statements
um
retirement benefit information it
depends there are different requirements
if you're married or unmarried but
the financial affidavit is not the only
financial document that is required uh
in these cases
can I have a follow-up Madam chair yes
go ahead thank you uh now with the
example you gave I
I couldn't follow what the I couldn't
follow what the uh what the issue was
um you know on the I'm the abuser who is
seeking child support and you're saying
this will have the
mother uh not be able to afford an
attorney
well so because you've got to prioritize
child support payments right under this
so she wants to comply wants to pay her
child support but also needs an attorney
to show that the child support order
that the court may have issued is
incorrect because he's underemployed and
somebody who is not skilled or doesn't
understand the court rules I mean
attorneys have a hard time doing this so
someone who is self-represented trying
to go to court against her abuser to
show that a child support Ward is
incorrect and or that the award should
go to her
would be really challenging to do
without an attorney and I think that's
what this bill does it essentially says
you can't get an attorney and that's an
access to justice issue okay just one
more follow-up if I may it'll be brief
thank you
um so am I hearing you correctly I want
to be clear on what you're saying so I'm
hearing you correctly that it's it's
it's more important for the mother in
this example to be able to use her money
for an attorney than it is to pay child
support
I'm saying it's an access to justice
issue to make sure that the person who
should be receiving the child support
and the correct child support award that
that is important child I'm not
disputing that child support is an
important obligation and that children
should absolutely come first but we need
to make sure that the child support
award is going to the appropriate parent
um and sometimes the way to do that
because abusers can use the system to
work against the victim sometimes the
way to do that is to hire an attorney
and I will also point out that when the
litigation is going on if there's a
child support award there's in a rearage
building it's not saying this person's
not going to be responsible for child
support there will be in a rearage
building and that money will be owed at
some point to one of the parties once
the litigation concludes
are you outside representative
okay are there any other questions
seeing representative on your good
of being done thank you very much
thank you for your time
and is there anyone else ahead of time
that would like to testify
Richard head
um good uh good morning uh uh Madam
chair and members of the committee my
name is Richard head I'm the government
Affairs coordinator for the judicial
branch we don't have any position on
this bill I just and normally these are
comments that I would make in a work
session but I honestly don't know how
work sessions work this year
so I'm just going to to raise a couple
points which which really relate to just
the mechanics of how this bill would
work
um and what the court system's role
would be so if if for example if there's
priority to child support
but a lawyer has been paid by a retainer
how does that impact the retainer if a
child if if the costs or payments are
um
are charged by the court and child
support is an ongoing obligation how
would that work if the first child
support payment is made payment of the
costs and fees are made but then
subsequent child support is not made
does that somehow impact
um how those fees and costs are being
paid or is there some other obligation
so it's more or less just the mechanics
that are unclear in the language of the
bill which I would normally talk through
in a work session
but not knowing the process this year
I'm just raising it as questions for the
committee to consider this year thank
you and by the way I don't pretend to be
an expert in in family law on the court
process for family law but just have
these these concerns but again the court
system has no position relative to the
policies in this bill
well thank you are there any questions
seeing none thank you very much thank
you thank you for your time today
hey so I don't see any other hands up so
we have
yeah
we had representative Alicea your hand
is up Madam chair uh did any of the
speakers have written testimony
I don't not that I have
unless he emailed in but
you know I have the emailed one I'm just
double checking
thank you okay so we had
um
let's see
one person opposed one person neutral
and two support
who from the Senate support so I'm going
to close the hearing on House Bill 541
and then I'm going to give the clerk a
minute
get ready for the hearing on House Bill
228.
[Music]
I'm ready Madam chair
yes
all right so I'll open the hearing on
House Bill 228
and I will call up a representative Deb
DeSimone
thank you madam chair
representative Dallas Sayer can you hear
me
thank you madam chair
um and members of the committee and the
father who was his name
that was Bill 228 uh
it is relative to the calculation of
classified increases with equal or
unfortunately equal parenting time is
given to those parents and it seems to
be an inequity in that area of the law
and
um so that's why this bill was brought
forward
and I will
defer all comments
um
uh attorney J Marquette
thank you representative DeSimone so you
won't be taking questions you'll be
deferring them to attorney Markel that
is correct okay great all right so next
up we have Marilyn Mahoney he's taken
opposition for five minutes
thank you madam chair hello and good
morning
um I'm an attorney who has practiced in
family law for about 40 years I did
submit a summary of my testimony to the
committee by email this morning
um in effect this bill
um
as well as a bill that you're hearing
later today
House Bill 161 I believe both addressed
the issue of what happens for child
support when parents have
well in one bill it's called shared
parenting time and in the other bill
it's called equal or approximately
equals parenting time
if this bill uses the term I believe
um equal or approximately equal
and it refers to any of those cases in
which there is quote a disparity of
income
the two bills that are before the
committee are in are conflict uh in in
some significant ways
and they also would make a significant
change in what the current law is I
think it's important for the committee
to keep in mind that
every family every
parent and every parent's economic
situation and and family situation is
different and unique
concern I have particularly with this
bill is that it creates a rebuttable
presumption
the rebuttable presumption is really the
biggest flaw I believe this bill has
because it in effect
over would override
existing Provisions in New Hampshire law
that allows the court or the parties
when they're trying to
um negotiate a settlement
from being able to take into
consideration the various factors so for
example it is the case I believe in most
families where one parent is going to be
paying for daycare one parent is going
to be buying more clothes that may not
be the same parent
one parent is going to be incurring more
of the expenses for a child say for
school supplies or or extracurricular
activities
that
um
the the results in uh um
even though they have equal time or
approximately equal time not an equal
economic impact and those factors which
I said are currently allowed to be
considered in in current law would be
overridden by creating a rebuttable
presumption
and I think that using that term is
problematic the formula that's laid out
that is that you do a set off between
each party's income is commonly used now
it's not required by law but people do
it all the time use it all the time as a
kind of a guideline and it in in and of
itself I don't believe is a bad idea I
think the bad idea in this bill is
making it a rebuttable presumption
given that there are these two competing
bills and the other bill is is much more
complex in terms of the changes it makes
to existing law
it would be my suggestion to the
committee to perhaps have these both
bills referred to an interim study and
look at those kinds of changes that
would be made to current law and look
for a way to equitably
um and reasonably
um
implement the concept of the formula
without
shortchanging
um
families that are struggling in any case
trying to make ends meet with children
that completes my testimony
thank you are there any
questions for attorney Mahoney
thank you very much for your testimony
thank you for allowing me to testify
up next is Brenda town a member of her
of the public to speak in our position
she's asked for three minutes
oh good morning everybody and thank you
for allowing the testimony today
um I wanted to start by saying I'm a
grandmother of four grandkids I've gone
through the family courts personally
that exposure had has led me to become
an advocate for parents I currently lead
um a couple New Hampshire parents
organizations one with 3 500 followers
on Facebook where we try to help parents
navigate their way through family court
issues and also to become stronger and
better family units I'm going to be
speaking on child support today on
multiple calls but I did want to speak
specifically to this issue for the past
two and a half years I've worked with
both the sponsors committee members and
the UNH research team that was
commissioned to address child support in
New Hampshire
um so I'm just going to touch quickly on
the history of What's led us here today
and why this year this family court
sorry this uh child and family law
committee really owes it to the judges
and the families to make a directive on
how we address this Gap in our
legislation so in 2015 HB 378 was
introduced it was a shared parenting
bill but it was transitioned into a
study to be commissioned by UNH car seat
school on our entire child support
situation here in New Hampshire
in 2018 They concluded their study and
they prepared that for review here for
this Committee in 2019 UNH came to this
committee and presented their results
and unfortunately there was a
significant calculation error in their
report on shared parenting that didn't
get corrected until January of 2020.
unh's study was exhaustive it took
multiple years and it cost this state
half a million dollars
the study concluded with three important
recommendations and one of those
recommendations was that we needed a
standardized calculation for Shared
Parenting
complicating the situation is we have
two Supreme Court cases in the state of
New Hampshire that have now taken the
discretion of our family court judges
away in determining family
um sorry shared child support
cases in equitable distribution of child
support in 2018 there was a k Silva V
Silva which it was ruled in the state of
New Hampshire that the family court
judge could not
allocate anything different than the
child support calculator unless there
was a determination that fixed costs
were reduced on the obligee's side so
what that did is it prevented a judge
from making a a call of smoothing out
those child support cases where parents
were sharing significant time and
expenses
this was followed in 2019 with Case
Anderson V Anderson in our own New
Hampshire Supreme Court which then
basically pushed back the responsibility
of determining an equitable child
support
calculation for parents
um in the um case of shared child
support back to this family committee
because there is no legislation that a
judge can use to make an equitable
determination of Child Support so I know
that's a lot of language guys but I
thought it was important you had that
history because there's a lot of effort
that brought this committee to this
point
last year and the year before we had a
bill that was brought before this
committee HB 362. it is identical to
Deb's bill today it was put out for
interim study the challenges with the
bill were that it didn't
yeah excuse me please refer to the
members as representative de Simone okay
I'm sorry uh representative D Simone um
uh brought to the committee this bill
that is um in line with the HB 362 that
this committee had reviewed the prior
two years HB 362 was put out for interim
study and was was actually passed by
this committee to not bring for a vote
because it is missing some critical
information it doesn't Define parenting
time it doesn't Define approximate or
equal parenting time it doesn't reflect
any of the UNH recommendations and it
doesn't cover the spectrum of parenting
time other than approximate or equal
so what I would recommend and what I'm
going to recommend today is that the
committee take under consideration HP
161 which is a comprehensive bill that
reflects the half a million dollar study
that the state of New Hampshire has
commissioned
excuse me
I need you to stay on 228 you can
testify to 161 at the next hearing
people to testify on this specific Bill
okay I will I'm sorry Deb uh sorry
representative rice I I chair rice I
will try to stay on task so my my uh
issues with the bill are not that um in
fact we are addressing the shortcoming
in our legislation but that
unfortunately is uh falls short
um in the areas that were identified in
last session preventing us from moving
forward with this bill to the floor for
a vote thank you very much
are there any questions for miss cam
all right staying done thank you very
much
up next is um Aaron Justina to speak in
support and she's requested two minutes
Madam chair thank you um I actually need
to correct that we are
um signing in in opposition to this bill
and I will just say
um that we agree with Marilyn Mahoney
um in referring this bill to interim
study thank you and I apologize for the
inconvenience no problem thank you so
much are there any questions for Mr Cena
hey see you again thank you and up next
is um attorney Jane Markle and he put
down zero minutes but I'm gonna let you
have a few okay oh okay uh thank you um
I had signed in I thought for five
minutes uh briefly to address this bill
what it does is I have also submitted
some uh some written information on it
uh basically what this bill does is IT
addresses disparity of income issues the
offset method as was previously
testified to is a very well accepted way
of equalizing the child support between
the parties uh between the party's
income so it's pretty it's pretty easy
to understand it's simple to calculate
the holes in the law that it tries to
address are the Draconian results of
Silva uh which was previously alluded to
um contrary to what I think I heard
before there is absolutely nothing in
this bill that in any way limits the
balance of our RSA Force 458 C5 because
it leaves intact and provides for
additional flexibility additional
arguments to be made as to why a child
support should be up or down the
presumptive order means that it's a
rebuttable presumption rebuttable
presumptions exist fairly all over the
place in law and what this does is is
that in essence it allows courts to
craft individual solutions to to the
problems that that come in four of it in
terms of determining child support so
the calculations are real simple it's
done as first in the first instance as
if parent a plays parent B then if
parent B were to pay parent a then take
the difference in the support order and
the difference in the support order in
the first instance goes to the lower
income parent as the child support
that's presumptive now all the other
side really has to do is just look at
the balance of the statute because it
retains all of the virtues of the
existing statute it retains RSA uh
um 458 C5 adjustments to the
applications of the guidelines under
special circumstances so what it does
and contrary to the representations I
heard is gives enormous flexibility to a
court to be able to craft individual
solutions to a problem nobody gets
painted into a corner it allows the
court to consider the parenting schedule
it does not and I think it's pretty well
understood what equal or approximately
equal parenting time is it should not be
micromanaged priorities are free to
argue their cases as to whether they
whether or not they actually do have
equal or approximately equal parenting
time uh the courts can figure out what
that is that can be a variety of
circumstances it can be one week with
one parent one week with another parent
that can be a shared residential program
or it can be any number of days in
between as the parties out okay remember
this is not one size fits all this is
designed so that the courts have
flexibility to stay within the
guidelines and create individuals and
create individual orders that are fair
and once again the person who spoke
before said
the Silva case presented as I pointed
out in my written testimony presents
Draconian options where they're simply
not necessary the Anderson case as I
remember presented something similar to
this uh to the New Hampshire Supreme
Court and the New Hampshire Supreme
Court said your argument is not with us
it's with the legislature so this is
entirely appropriate in addition to
which
um Massachusetts below uh tried using uh
percentage-based formulas they found out
that in their situation on a six on a
six-year study that it simply wasn't
workable this will and basically what
this bill does is solve the problems it
provides predictable results it also has
the regular checks to make sure that the
child that the child support order is
adequate and that's why that language
stays in there it changes very little
but just what it does is solve a problem
and it does that rather effectively
using well-accepted means
um thanks for your time would be happy
to answer any questions
great thank you very much representative
foreign
thank you it takes about four clicks to
get unmuted so uh thanks for your
patience and thank you for taking my
question
um I'm looking at this legislation and
it is an entirely
um new paragraph to be added into
statute and the part that I'm struggling
with and I I need some clarification
because
um I just don't understand this is lines
10 through 12 okay so the amount of
child support payment shall then be
calculated according to the guidelines
as if the higher income party were to
pay the lower income party
and then
calculated as if the lower income party
were to pay the higher income party so
that just I
in my experience and I will admit it's
limited
that's not a thing
so when I when one party is at a
significant
um
income disparity to the other one
we don't make that calculation and so to
insert that seems to be creating
um creating a formula that's based on
an impossibility so I'm I'm really
confused about this okay I'm glad to a
good question happy to answer it what
happens is is that okay let me start off
by saying that neither the legislation
uh the present legislation nor Silva
actually defined what a disparity of
income was so uh to trigger a full
guidelines order so was that a
difference of a hundred dollars a month
a thousand dollars a month two three
four thousand dollars a month it's
unclear and the present legislation
doesn't do that okay uh now as to the
child support calculation it would go
like this
um when I say parent a and parent B so
one parent let's say for the sake of
argument makes five thousand dollars a
month and the other one makes two
thousand dollars a month and there's a
three thousand dollar disparity so the
parent making five thousand dollars a
month the calculation is the five
thousand dollar parent okay
does a calculation as if the five
thousand dollar parent were to pay the
two thousand dollar parent the two
thousand dollar parent then makes the
calculation as if the two thousand
dollar parent were to pay the five
thousand dollar parent the difference
between those two numbers okay you take
the higher you take the lower number
subtract it from the higher number okay
that difference goes to the lower income
parent okay and that's a presumptive
order now the rest of the statute States
completely in place and then the court
is free to do a check and not only that
the other party is free to argue that
that is not a correct order based on the
entire statute okay absolutely very
little changes
um what it does is that it gives you
predictability so for example if a child
support order would a result from higher
to lower would be two hundred dollars a
month from the higher income parent and
the lower income parent would have paid
the higher income parent a hundred
dollars a month the difference is a
hundred dollars that hundred dollars
goes to the lower income parent now if
for any reason that order is not deemed
adequate okay that party is free to
argue to the court but judge it's not
adequate and I'm going to ask you to
take into considerations the following
adjustments that we need to make it's
all right there in the statute and the
parties are free to argue all it does is
it gives you a jumping off point and
then the parties are free and it's going
to solve a big problem because I think
as attorney Mahoney indicated it's been
in common use well this does not
reinvent anything this is not new or
novel and point of fact I'm referring to
uh what I consider to be the Bible in
this particular case which is child
support guidelines and application by
Laura Morgan uh Second Edition from 2020
who's probably one of the leading
authorities in the United States on
child support she recognizes and has
been widely recognized is that the
offset method is what's being used okay
to determine a lot of Child Support
calculations so this is nothing new it's
generally well accepted once again I
would refer to people who did a six-year
study the Massachusetts court system did
a six-year study and they concluded in
their 2018 guidelines that percentages
don't work and they use a variation of
the same thing and we know what shared
residential responsibility is you know
if it's six days or approximately equal
courts can make that determination along
with the parties
I hope I answered your question
um May I follow up
follow up
thank you so
um
I'm trying to keep up with you here and
my question now is do you think that
this
um as it's written here can be used to
put a price tag on parenting time
I'm not sure I understand what you mean
madam
would parenting time be given a a
denomination of value in the child
support well
um
the idea Financial incentive
okay
um well this kind of takes the financial
incentive out of it this is the whole
point because right now what you have is
child support driving the parenting plan
and people fighting over this what this
does is this frees parents to be parents
and uh makes child support has to be
adequate but it also should be fair and
easy to determine and transparent and
that's what this is
are you all set representative Bachelor
um yeah I just I think one of the things
that's kind of sticking at me is the um
you know as this is written it assumes
that the parents are in agreement and if
there is you know if they're not in
agreement
I guess I guess my question would be in
line four
where like
how would a pro se parent know that they
have to know that there's a rebuttable
presumption and know what they have to
do
um to
to repeat that
particularly if that's not you know an
agreeable
separation
well
um once again parties okay well the law
is published online and I respectfully
point out that parties really should be
reading the even Pro seis should be
looking at the law online to determine
what their rights and obligations are
now obviously that may or may not happen
Okay but
um you know there there's certainly free
to look up a lot of sources it's there
the law is there for everyone to see and
one of the virtues of this is that it's
easy to understand let's put it this way
I can understand how it would be foreign
if you're not used to working with it
okay and it would confuse any and let's
put it this way I can understand that
but when you're used to working with it
and the judges understand it and the
parties can look at that and say well
wait a minute
um I make this she makes that uh she
makes this he makes this I make that so
this is what my child support payment
would be okay now I'm going to ask for
more money because the order wouldn't be
adequate from my point of view whether
you're whoever you are uh parenting time
I don't know that you can quantify it
but it involves Mutual obligation uh the
other thing is is that it frees parents
to be able to focus on their kids and
involve in parenting and develop a
parenting plan rather than fighting over
the Draconian results of what would be a
presumptively unfair child support order
great thank you representative law
ah thank you madam chair uh thank you uh
attorney Markle
um just to say when you answer my
question uh with all due respect I I get
it after a couple of sentences when you
get into the five or six I lose my whole
thought so it would help me if it would
just be precise
um so with respect to uh proceed do you
believe this would be more complicated
for them to figure out I think it would
be less complicated than a competing
bill
okay
um and also on um if if both parties
came and agreed to everything is that
still eligible if this became law
um yes it is in fact what it does is it
allows for example it allows parties to
argue their cases individually this
paints nobody into a corner okay so for
example I'll give you some scenarios if
I don't need I don't need a scenarios I
I because I'm going to get lost okay uh
if I could follow up Madam speaker no
follow up thank you
um so
you're talking about the parties arguing
and I'm talking about my question was on
if
if the two parties agree on everything
who's getting paid what who's paying for
the dance lessons they agree on
everything
does this still have to be
um implied that do they still have to go
through this calculation
go ahead
okay uh they probably do but let me
explain that's just a function of Child
Support worksheets that's all because
every every child support case has to be
accompanied by child support worksheets
okay and then the court is free to make
its individual findings
yeah so so
of course thank you thank you attorney
Michael
um
I'm I'm trying to look at the uh I'm
trying to look at the content you know
contentious litigations
um and how this
um you know very
hard calculation in my mind I mean I
know it's easy in your mind but in mine
it's not
um how this will impact you know I'm
looking for you know they don't see an
opportunity where
um
there's an incentive to uh not be
forthcoming on some issues when you're
when you're doing the calculation like
this because let's see at my real five
thousand dollar a month salary I pay
this
but at my 4500
dollar salary I'll pay X
um so you don't do you see incentives to
circumventing uh
where there's more angles to circumvent
this
um oh okay I see well that's a common
problem and it has that and um uh
understating income becoming unemployed
uh imputation of incomes our problems
common to uh many divorce and parenting
cases across the board this would uh not
stand out one way or the other uh you
know there are always questions with
financial affidavits and whether or not
parties are being forthright as to their
income
um I don't think this has Effect one way
or the other
okay thank you madam chair
thank you very much
um and also can I just ask everyone to
slow down a little bit when they're
talking because the clerk is trying to
keep up with everything
um representative you have a question
yes I do Madam chair thank you
for me it is difficult to understand
um uh section 3B I think we're TR uh
since I don't have the background I
fortunately have never been involved in
the child support situation and uh if
someone attorney Markle for facts could
provide us with some background and also
turn the attempt there to do uh
basically uh put down arithmetic in text
I think if it were presented offline as
uh
the arithmetic it would be easier for me
to understand thank you yes so so
attorney Mark Howe my thought was
perhaps you could put together some sort
of a diagram that explains how we have
the two thousand three thousand and how
it intersects and meets and comes up
with something if you could set up some
sort of a diagram for us and email us or
something I think that would be very
helpful okay be happy to do it sure I
can give you some examples of how the
calculation works is that what I'm I'm
is that what I'm hearing is what you're
looking for
okay I can do that
okay great thank you very much
will that will that yes thank you madam
cheers
thank you
thank you turning mark
hey that's the last of the people on the
list and now I have two people who want
to speak
and the attendees and you're going to
have to be brief because we are now over
time so
um Bill Woodbury
already done
Mr Woodbury can you unmute
yes Madam chair can you hear me now yes
thank you
thank you and I'm sorry I didn't uh sign
up sign up earlier I will be very brief
um my name is Bill Woodbury I am an
attorney practicing in the City of
Laconia I practice primarily in family
law uh but also in other areas and I'm
also the legislative chair for the New
Hampshire Association for justice
um and
we uh
suppose I'm we're speaking in opposition
uh to this bill I would Echo the
thoughts of
um attorney Mahoney uh with respect to
uh study of both 228 and 161
um that I would disagree with attorney
Markle uh respectfully uh that you know
this this bill would take the financial
incentive out of this we oppose because
we believe
um and I would Echo the thoughts of uh
representative altshuler that
um anytime you you try and fold into the
calculation
the
um the parenting time then you create an
incentive for people to fight for more
parenting time solely because it will
potentially cost them less money
um so I was asked to be brief and I will
be but that is our position in this that
this you know should never be folded
into the child support calculation it
creates a a
um an appropriate incentive I'll take
any questions people may have
thank you attorney Woodbury
um I have a quick question but would you
agree that right now there's Financial
incentive that people go to bat fighting
left and right because they don't want
to pay child support or they feel
they're paying too much so they they
tend to drag out the court cases for you
know longer periods of time to try to
get the more parenting time because they
think in their mind that it's going to
lower their child support
uh representative writes it is a it is a
battle that I fight on a daily basis
however right now there is no incentive
for someone to say I want more time
because I'll pay less
and that is why these bills shouldn't
pass okay thank you representative
okay I only took two clicks to unmute
this time thank you uh thank you thank
you for um taking my question
um attorney Woodbury so
um
here on the Seacoast I want to I want to
give you an example and see if I'm
understanding what this legislation will
do
um we've actually had a very public case
where uh a father was physically abusive
um to the mother
um and
was caught being physically abusive and
subsequently charged uh with domestic
violence Mom leaves right is able to
separate from parent takes kids with her
she's employed she has a job and she's
able to go back to her job dad loses the
job because his
um abuse is now known and there is no
longer trust in him to
do his job that he had because it
required public trust and there's bad
press around it because I'm trying to
kill your wife doesn't really you know
do a lot for your job prospects so now
he's underemployed
um where's the incentive for him to get
another kind of work or to get work at
all
while his wife is employed and
supporting those children what's the
incentive under this statute if it were
to come to pass for him to go forward
and actually get work
uh I mean it in that particular
situation I mean there's a there's a
number of things occurring there and
there's a number of motivations that he
has to continue kind of maintaining this
you know this uh negative behavior but
it the the problem specifically here is
that that a person who is voluntarily
underemployed uh voluntarily unemployed
um or who simply does not want to you
know pay more money has an incentive to
argue that they're that's in the best
interest of the children to have equal
parenting time between the parents
um where that incentive does not exist
now everything is based on income and
the reason being is that child support
the specific intent of Child Support is
to equilibrate the economic experience
between the households
and um in in the situation that you
mentioned and in in a myriad of other
situations an individual who's looking
to game the system by
um by you know creating in this case a
rebuttable presumption that equal
parenting time should reduce their child
support obligation that is the the
problem we see with this and in 161 we
would go again we would Echo the
comments of attorney Mahoney that this
should go to study
thank you
are there questions
thank you attorney wood Barry thank you
I see
one more person with their hand raised
in the
attendees
Christians we're almost out of time on
this so I can give you two minutes and
then to the John that raised his hand I
can give you two minutes but we are out
of time on this earring
so Kristen Smith
hi thank you for um taking my uh comment
um I'm Kristen Smith can you hear me
yeah
um I'm Kristen Smith I was one of the
co-authors of the child support report
um so I would just encourage you to take
a look at
um the third recommendation which lays
out the um
the Shared Parenting
um
proposal I'm neutral on this bill I just
want that to be out there
um and if you want some examples of how
different earnings and different
scenarios of parenting time would
influence
the proposed
changes in this bill that's a good place
for you to look the other thing that I
would just point out is that the bill
does not stipulate how parenting time
will be calculated so when I read it I
did not see whether this would be
measured in overnights or whether this
would be measured in
um you know time spent with children
so that is an um oversight in the in the
bill as well as we also recommended
um that there needs to be exceptions
when parenting time is addressed to
ensure appropriate safeguards are
included particularly in cases with
intimate partner violence to guarantee
safety for the child and the abused
parent so that um sort of comes back to
what a representative else Tyler was
just talking about
um I'm happy to meet with committee
members if you have questions about the
report thank you
is there any questions for Miss Smith
all right see you again thank you very
much
next is John
this John
you have two minutes
yes uh
I just want to point out there's no I
don't see a threshold for parenting time
in this bill
and I believe it's based on the UNH
study which did have a threshold of 30
percent
and I'm wondering why there's no
threshold in this bill
so here secondly why okay but but you
can't ask questions
I'm sorry
okay last point I would recommend if uh
if this is past that the uh it would
start on April 1st
um
2022 that would coincide with a major
update to child support that the
division of
performs on April 1st every year
so that would eliminate two major
changes they would have to do
okay
are there any questions John can we get
your last name for the record please
you need to unmute
I I've had trouble with my connection so
I haven't heard the entire meeting you
need your you need your
um
your last name for the record
yes it's a b l a s
V is in Victory
yeah
are there any questions for John
seeing that thank you very much
and that's
that's
it all right so that's that's all we
have for Testimony so um we had two
sign-in supports six in opposition and
four that were neutral and so I'm
closing hearing on House Bill 228.
I'm going to give the clerk a minute to
get ready for
um
house bill 161.
thank you madam cheer
okay
so
um representative yokella would you like
to introduce your bill I don't have you
signed up on here
representative yes yes thank you I'm
sorry I'm not signed up I'm not sure
about that
um keep in mind we're running a little
behind
okay
hello
um
thank you
Madam chairman and uh members of the
committee
I'm here to present hb161
this bill was worked on for a
significant amount of time last session
um as
response to the 2018 child support
guidelines review
and the those guidelines
recommended that we do three things it
recommended that the New Hampshire child
support guidelines table be updated
it recommended that we
increase the self-support reserve from
115 percent to 120 of the national or of
the federal poverty line and it
suggested that we enact changes to the
guidelines uh to address shared
parenting and those three things are
what this bill does
it um the simplest thing is just
changing the 115 to 120 for the federal
poverty line
uh the child support uh percentages
uh recommended by the review are in the
the actual report and the only addition
made to that was for a fourth child it
only
did percentages up to three children and
uh the calculation was kind of followed
out to the fourth child and that is
included in the legislation
and then came
the
um recommendation that we address shared
parenting time and it recommended that
we
as you heard earlier it recommended that
we set uh a floor for what is shared
parenting time so that the courts will
know and it recommended 30 percent and
that's what this bill does it also
recommended that
when you have to
to households
um parenting
that the costs of maintaining those
households is higher than
one household and so it recommended that
you multiply the
um the amount of Child Support or the
amount required to support the child to
be multiplied by 1.5 percent and that
recommendation is also
um added to the bill
and it also wanted uh
the change
for child support to be
based on how much time was given so if
you have 50 percent you'll get more
credit towards supporting your child
because when they're with with your um
with you then you are spending that
money uh to support the child
you get more credit if you have 50 than
if you had 40 and you get more if you
have 40 than if you have 30 whereas
um and so those calculations
are uh all included in this bill
and
I wanted to uh
help give
an example of that
by
let's see I wanted to
share some information that
you guys
were
seeing in
I don't think we have the ability to
share on the screen
if there's some I'm pretty sure we do
is this sharing
yeah can you see this great
so
so I can you see this uh scenario one on
your screen
can you see this I can yeah I can I can
see it
yeah I have to check I'm not sure that
we were allowing
um
things to be shared on screen because
the only panelists can do it but the um
members of the public can't yeah well
this is an important part of the aspect
so that we address the issues
um of people being able to understand
how this this is
um you know it was just recommended that
we share
um in the last bill some examples so
that people would be able to follow the
logic so
I think this is important
um that we do
be able to see this so in this this
first scenario the people have the same
uh amount of
income
and the percentage of the child support
amount is based on that income and then
there is a credit which is and then that
amount is Multiplied because this is a
shared parenting formula or a shared
parenting situation uh it's multiplied
by the 1.5 percent and then
the person gets a credit for the amount
of time so in this situation they both
earn the same amount they both have the
child for the same amount of time and so
there's no obvious obligation required
whereas in scenario two
one the obligor earns more than the
obligee and it the amount of parenting
time is the same
but the obligation
is uh
is where the obligee or the obligorn
needs to pay the obligee uh an amount to
offset based on the amount of money that
they of the difference of the money uh
the obligor in this case earns 59
whereas the obligee earns 41 of the
household income
and
so in scenario three the there's a
difference of the credit there's a
difference in the earning from the
obligee and the obligor and there's a
difference in the parenting time it's
only 40 percent instead of 50 and so you
can see that when you multiply the total
amount
um the adjusted amount for for shared
child support obligation
you multiply that by 40 and that is the
credit that that person gets towards
their obligation and so
there is an amount reflective of both
the difference in income and obviously
the difference in
um parenting time and so that is all
that I wanted to
um show you guys have a copy of those
slides in your email
and um so I just wanted to give that
information so that you would um be able
to make a decision on this on this issue
uh I'm happy uh so so another thing one
last thing that I wanted to point out
was that in the recommendations from the
2018 child support guidelines I think
that uh it's important to point out that
the recommendation is that we adopt all
of the recommendations of the of the
report and not just pick and choose
because that can have some negative
impacts and so this bill actually tries
to address
all the recommendations and Implement
them
um I thank you and uh happy to take
questions
oh
[Music]
I'm sorry I think I hadn't taken my hand
down from the last time sorry
okay
are there any
um questions representative Bill answer
uh thank you madam chair and thank you
representative Ocala for for your
introduction in this bill
um
I guess
I guess being new I'm a little kind of
confused between 161 and 228 are they
it sounds like you're addressing the
parenting time but as is 228 so can you
just kind of
yes I'm happy to I'm happy to help so um
228 the language firm that came out
before the report for the review
guidelines and so it does not
incorporate the recommendations it just
identified one of the problems in our
child support system and does not really
address the entire thing which 161 is
trying to do and is trying to implement
those changes
and so it's completely apples and
oranges between the two even though it's
it's also personally trying to address
the same it would pick up and work
session okay okay
um so that we can distinguish the the
two
um
representative long
thank you madam chair uh thank you
representative
um
30 or more of the time
is that two nights a week
seven days
what what do you know what do you know
what that is how much time or how much
overnights how many overnights that is
so it would be more it's it's um in
between it's more than two but less than
three so
you know if you had you know two nights
a week and then some other you know
rotating layers seven nights is a
hundred percent right okay thank you uh
and one other question
um the one and a half calculation wait
where how did that come about
well it's it's recommended in the um
child support guidelines
yeah okay
okay
Madam chair the the uh
now that we're putting this into statues
is that can you just slow down a little
bit the questions are coming really fast
okay
so if you want
the uh so I'm asking if um
the fact that you put these calculations
in
at the end of the year can I get a
reimbursement because I said I was
calculated for 30 but when I did my
records it was actually 45
so this so this would be
um based on the plan that you create so
so it would be the plan would be
encompassing the whole year like maybe
you have weekends and holidays and stuff
like that that would be incorporated for
the whole year and so if there was a
change you would need to file for an
adjustment and prove that the change is
you know permanent et cetera et cetera
you know it wouldn't be just um you know
a rebate
thank you
hey any other questions for
representative yopella
representative Belanger
so
uh thank you madam chair
um representative
if a hundred percent is identified
can can you explain how a hundred
percent of parenting time would be
identified if someone is visiting with
their kids seven days a week are we
referring to
um percentages of days in one week or
the number of days per month that
they're visiting with the child
neither it would be it would be based on
so they would
the calculation is based on overnights
which was recommended inside the
guidelines and it is
the plan would be able to in Comfort
Compass an entire year so you would you
know you would say every other weekend
you know three weeks in the summer maybe
holidays et cetera et cetera and so all
of that will be stipulated and you would
find that calculation
via the whole year
thank you
okay I don't see any other questions
thank you very much representative
yocella
thank you
up next is Michael bear who is asking
for 60 minutes and I cannot give you 60
minutes I can give you five minutes
um you know everyone else has asked for
five minutes three minutes and two
minutes and we're already way behind so
I can give you five minutes but I cannot
give you an hour this hearing wasn't
even scheduled for an hour
so you just need to unmute
Mr bear
Mr bear are you there
all right we're gonna have to come back
until he can get unmuted so we'll go to
um Christopher Cianci who has requested
five minutes
and sticking to it
you have to unmute Mr ciancie
yes
hello can you hear me yes you have five
minutes all right so um I would just
like to say this bill
um
uh should be passed in um
I personally experienced
um having to pay the full
um
child support payment uh when I had
shared parenting and um
it really just negatively impacted
um you know my parenting time with the
kids
and it took a long time
um for it to get corrected but
I would just say uh this is something
that would
um prevent other people
um the hardship that we went through
is there any questions
thank you very much
Mr bear are you there can you unmute yet
Mr bear can you unmute yet
okay we'll go on to
um attorney Maryland who's the freaking
opposition to the bill
good morning again
um thank you very much for allowing me
to testify I am testifying in opposition
to this bill
um uh but oh but only for there are
certain specific
um Provisions that are are very
concerning
um
the devil is in the details as they say
and so as I look at this bill
um the the biggest concern one of the
biggest concerns I have is in providing
a specific definition for Shared
Parenting the definition uh with this is
right
but the fourth line from the beginning
of the text of the bill
is that it is where the child overnights
with each parent 30 or more of the time
my first concern is by counting shared
parenting as overnights
um it doesn't take much imagination to
realize that over at night is the least
expensive time to have a child with you
the expenses arise during the day
um and taking children to their
activities and providing them with food
overnights doesn't do that so I think
using the the calculation of overnights
is deeply flawed
the deeper concern I have is with the 30
percent
30 percent of anything it is certainly
not shared if I have a pie and I eat
two-thirds of it and only leave you with
less than a third we haven't we've
shared it but I don't think we've done
it in a way that is in any way close to
being equal or approximately equal
also the minute that you start to use a
specific percentage you drive up the
conflict in the parenting end of things
and suddenly the issue of who has the
child an additional overnight
um becomes a huge factor and you create
conflict in the place that you least
want it to be you may solve a problem
with child support but the parenting
issues relating to the child suddenly
become intensely
conflicted and and for all the wrong
reasons it becomes conflicted because of
the the
um the money and not about what's in the
best interest of the child
that phrase doesn't appear anywhere what
is in the best interest of the child
doesn't appear anywhere in this bill
with regard to that issue I think that
you you should
at least remove that
the phrase equal or approximately equal
has been recognized and understood
without
really any
um confusion as far as my experience has
been as to what that means and so
um you don't need that definition to be
replacing what the practice has been for
many many years
the other issue that I have is with the
repeal this is at the end of the bill a
repeal of RSA c51h1
that states that uh equal or
approximately equal parenting
residential responsibilities in and of
itself shall not eliminate the need for
child support and shall not by itself
constitute ground for an adjustment
that's crucial language that is referred
to all the time and that language should
remain in the statute it should not be
repealed
um I I have more concerns but I know the
time is short and I don't want to take
too much of your time so I urge the
committee to
um
send this as well as 228 to interim
study there's a lot of Merit to this
bill
as I said the devil's in those details
thank you very much
are there any questions representative
law thank you madam chair
um
so would language
like in uh nothing is paragraph shall
preclude a court for modification of the
presumptive child support orders such as
Justice and the best interest of the
child may require suffice some of your
concerns
no not really because
you've got to understand that probably
75 to 80 percent if not more of cases
settle and so the arguments and the
conflict occurs much earlier than that
provision would apply
are there any further questions
thank you very much
thank you
up next is Brenda town and she has asked
for three minutes
thank you chairman
um and thank you members of the
committee um I wanted again to speak in
support of this bill
um as we are looking at this huge gap in
our current legislation we are having
parents faced with significant financial
hardship
it has been well studied that equal and
shared parenting time actually creates
the most healthy viable children short
of an intact marriage and what we're
finding is that we are as a state
adopting more and more uh shared
parenting but unfortunately our child
support orders have not kept pace
and so we end up with one parent because
of the outcome of Silva V Silva bearing
the entire financial burden
um of the child support while the other
parent is participating in full
parenting responsibility up to as much
as 50 of the time and yet gets no
Financial relief in my role
um as a parent support Advocate I have
met parents that are struggling um to be
able to meet the needs of their kids
because compounding the matter is that
our DHHS policies around food stamps
child care and all the other state aid
that we provide low-income parents did
not keep Pace with the move to Shared
Parenting so typically that secondary
parent does not have access to those
benefits as well I'd like to point out
that HB 161 is a direct reflection of a
very deep dive study that was done on
behalf of New Hampshire that study is
posted out on our DHHS website and is a
reflection of the direction our state
was committed to going into as an
outcome of that study and I really
appreciate Kristen Smith uh dialing in
today because she interviewed along with
her research Partners thousands of
lawyers gals and judges in order to get
the outcome and there was a outcry by
our illegal system for standardized
calculations because it takes the
mystery out in in it drops the level of
contention on this very tricky area and
without contention on the front end we
create a better situation for our kids
because parents aren't fighting over
this stuff I'd like to point out this um
calculation has been in practice in
Vermont for over eight years
successfully this is not something new
that we're wading into and the gaps that
we've historically struggled with which
include a lack of definition around what
shared parenting is a lack of definition
around
um uh around this entire calculation
will be remedied with this bill in many
many parents here in the state will be
removed from financial hardship it's the
responsibility of this committee to
bring forward legislation and not kick
out another round of study because we've
done that since 2005 and we really owe
it to our parents here in New Hampshire
to reconcile this situation once and for
all and I just speak for those kids who
are stuck in the middle and are really
looking for us to step it up and match
what other states in this country have
easily been able to tackle so um again
I'd be glad to answer any questions and
I thank you again for all listening and
your participation in this family
committee
representative long
thank you madam chair thank you uh it's
called the great great testimony
um now is Vermont solely on overnight
also yes they use this exact
prescription so when you know UNH did
all of their work through the car seat
school they looked at Best Practices and
um this was a best practice that they
identified that met the gaps that our
judges and our lawyers and our gals came
forward with
um the only other thing I'd like to add
that I didn't include in my testimony is
that last year when we were trying to
remedy the HB 362 issue
um and it had been recommended to go out
to interim study I had an opportunity to
meet with our title 4D as well as judge
Ashley the assistant administrative
judge in our family courts and both of
them endorsed getting to the
standardized calculation because it will
preclude a lot of the front and acrimony
that affects parenting so again thank
you guys very much
are there any further are there any
further questions from this town
representative Belanger
uh thank you madam chair
um Miss town just to kind of confirm are
you saying that the judicial system
supports this bill I didn't quite
we did not have the exact draft of this
bill in front of them what I will tell
you is that they were very um supportive
of having a standardized calculation to
take the mystery out of shared parenting
which they typically find is an issue
between Family Court judges using their
own prescription
um it has created a Great Divide
um because some judges uh rule One Way
some do rule another way and it creates
a challenge so um judge Ashley was very
supportive of getting to the
standardized calculation
being none thank you very much thank you
guys have a good day let this hearing go
until 11 30. if we're not done by 11 30
I'm gonna have to recess it and we'll
have to come back another day to finish
because I I have another sharing that
was scheduled for 11 15. that we're
already cutting into
so up next is Derek Yates
foreign
is there a Derek Yates
if they're there could you raise your
hand please
okay go on to the next one
Aaron Justina
Madam chair we have a Derrick champagne
that's unmuted
is that the person
I asked Derek Yates to raise his hand
Derek champagne are you there at the 80s
pardon me okay
no ma'am okay thank you
um Aaron Jacina
thank you madam chair I'll be very brief
um I direct the domestic violence
advocacy project at New Hampshire legal
assistance and we are testifying in
foreign
can you hear me now here you are yep
did you hear any of it
no sorry Aaron Justina I directed
domestic violence advocacy project at
New Hampshire legal assistance we are
testifying in opposition of this bill I
will Echo the comments of attorney
Marilyn Mahoney and would recommend that
this bill go to interim study I will
just quickly say that when you tie child
support to the parent parenting time you
risk people seeking parenting time only
in an effort to reduce their child
support obligation which in an abusive
situation can put kids at risk and thank
you for your time
are there any questions foreign
representative long
thank you madam chair uh
yeah Mr Cena
um do you know the percentage of
cases that are tied in with abuse
representative long thank you for the
question I don't have an exact
percentage off the top of my head it's
certainly data that I can get to you
um I I there's some Court information
I'm sure that can be shared regarding
the percentage of cases involving
domestic violence sexual assault or
stalking
thank you
are there any further questions
thank you very much thank you for your
time
up next is Dennis Malloy and elected
official and he's asked for two minutes
good thank you yes uh I'm representative
Dennis Malloy from Greenland and this is
an example of a co-sponsor of this bill
and it's an example of constituent
Service uh you heard earlier from Brenda
Town who is a neighbor and uh brought
this to my attention
and uh I I met with a representative
yakola and uh representative abrami
about this and also I wanted to point
out that over the past year another
member I think of this committee uh The
Honorable skip Baron helped put some of
this together uh in what you're seeing
in this bill so it's uh and it's been
around a while uh it was again this is
my work on behalf of a constituent uh
that I felt was important to hear this
is at the uh I'm laying this uh
representative and Ireland at the feet
of the committee to consider and work
through I don't have charts I don't have
the detail that others do this has not
been an experience that I've ever
personally had to go through but I just
wanted to come in and say uh I'm
supporting uh Miss town and others on
the committee who've worked to bring
this forward before so uh thank you for
your time and uh hearing my uh case for
this thank you
thank you are there any questions for
representative Malloy
all right seeing them thank you very
much representative
up next is attorney Markle
yes good uh good uh good morning again
uh can you hear me you have to be very
brief please okay real brief uh the
problems that I see with RS with the
proposed Bill are that if you want to
try to do an overhaul that's fine that
would go to study however just off the
top of my head given the fact that you
have about 60 to 70 percent of the uh
parties and cases are self-represented I
think the calculations may be difficult
to follow uh one thing the UNH study did
not do was examine the Practical
consequences of its recommendations not
in the copy that I saw uh the
Massachusetts system had done things
like percentages which other people have
already addressed they're not workable
the
um I don't think they're workable as was
previously mentioned uh what they do is
they focus on the fighting and the child
support and that drives the attempt on
the parenting plan
um the final thing I think that was not
mentioned was two things number one is
that
um you may be opening floodgates with
this in terms of pro seis not
understanding this approach to Shared
Parenting because if you have
percentages I can right now see the
modifications I can see the contempts
and I can see requests for reimbursement
because percentages weren't met for a
given month day or year and I can see
the courts being clogged with this from
Pro seis uh and finally which also
should be recognized is is that none of
uh is that
um I think when you look at the
parenting rights and responsibilities
act I think it's RSA 461a14 I think you
suppose the courts are still free to use
child support in a manner which is most
conducive to the child's benefit okay
which is the overriding concern so uh
that's kind of it in a nutshell
um I look forward to further submissions
and I thank the committee first time
are there any questions for attorney
Marco
saying that thank you very much
is Mr bear
available yet Michael Bear
raise your hand if you're there
all right so I'm going to go with
Marissa Chase
quickly
please
good morning can you hear me yes
okay good morning members of the
committee thank you for allowing me to
testify my name is Marissa Chase I'm the
executive director for the New Hampshire
Association for Justice Just wanted to
briefly Echo attorney Mahoney and
attorney
Justina from the New Hampshire legal
assistants we share those concerns
there's a phrase that stuck out in my
mind that I learned from working with
attorneys is criminal law brings out the
best in people Sammy law brings out the
worst in people it's a sad reality and
we would be happy to work with the
committee if these bills are going to
study attorney Woodbury had to hop off
because he is remotely teaching his son
but wanted to Echo his promise when the
previous bill on this as well thank you
thank you are there any questions from
Miss Jace
seeing none thank you very much and then
the last person testifying is Kristen
Smith
you have about two minutes Miss Smith
you just need to unmute yeah so it just
took me a minute to find
um so I just um I'm sorry when I
testified earlier I thought we were
talking about
um Hospital 161 I came in at 10 30. so
the comments that I made for I guess it
was Hospital 228 were in reference to
this bill
um which is
um
basically
having uh
I I do see now that there is uh that
overnights is in the bill so I apologize
for for missing that um but just not
having the any kind of accommodation
Ms Smith are you there
I think she may have accidentally gotten
bounced hold on here she comes
and Sam Smith are you there
you go
oh I apologize I'm not sure how that
went from
unmuted to muted
um
I was just saying that my comments
earlier were really in reference to
House Bill 161 I didn't realize that um
we were you were talking about a
different bill so I apologize for
jumping in then
um the one thing that I do want to just
bring your attention to in the report is
that 63 of the case of the child support
cases
um the the judges when they're
um when they're working through the
child support cases
um 63 deviate from the child support
guidelines and so
um we were asked
um at UNH to look at the child support
system and we were asked to look at what
a feasible
um shared parenting program would look
like and so we looked into what other
states have done and looked at Best
Practices and put forward this proposal
like I said earlier I'm neutral on this
bill
um but the
the The Proposal that we put forward
which looks like is well represented in
this bill is based on the research from
other states from what other states are
doing
um so the one exception that I would
um
would um like to just bring your
attention to is
um cases with intimate partner violence
and domestic abuse do need to have a
consideration and other other states are
doing that there's other people who have
spoken today who are better equipped to
give guidance on what that would look
like than I am but it is
um a provision that is in other states
and would be
um a really good safeguard for those
situations
um again I'm happy to talk about the
report with people who have questions on
the report
um that's it
thank you are there any questions for
Miss Smith
all right same none thank you very much
and thank you everyone for your
testimonies so we have 31 people sign in
and support six a post and two were
neutral and that will close the hearing
on House Bill 161.
I am now going to give the class time
to get ready
to open
house bill
317. so just let me know when you're
ready
Madam chair okay
okay so I'm going to open the hearing on
House Bill
317 this hearing is only going to go
until 12 15.
so I would ask that the speakers keep
that in mind please don't Echo other
testimony if you have something new to
add I encourage that but I I would
appreciate if we didn't get the same
testimony from everyone and please keep
it to your time and I I can't do a 30
minute
um hearing it this this
just can't go on that one
so I apologize so I'm going to call up
representative
um Al Val DeSaro to introduce his bill
there he is
a representative all the sorrow can you
unmute yourself
okay I just did the Young you finally
came up thank you can you hear me now
good morning Madam chair and uh fellow
representatives for the record I am
representative Al baldos Rockingham
County District 5 testifying from an
undisclosed location
uh I brought this bill forward uh HB 317
uh to correct a major problem within the
state a few years ago I brought this
bill forward and we were told by the
Supreme Court Justice lobbyists that the
state of New Hampshire does not go after
veterans disability uh they leave it
alone and I so the bill ended up dying
and I agreed with them because when I
got a divorce my disability was not
touched of course I got custody of my
daughter uh as I was a single father for
a while so it didn't affect me but I did
bring the federal law into court now we
have many veterans in the state of New
Hampshire that have called me and
complained about uh they're using their
disability some is causing homeless some
of the cases I'm here and cause suicide
on the veterans on putting them out in
the street
um
we try to get this corrected last time
yeah and then of course it went into
interstudy and um some of the veterans
that wanted to testify had problems on
were to zoom on their phones in their
car and other stuff there so I'm hoping
uh there are quite a few that are on
this here now let me go where I'm going
with this here this kid
um disability veterans disability which
I'm disabled veteran it affects many
many families and the reason why it does
male and female have the same problem so
this and it always is who ends up with
the children because no matter what
happens in the court somebody's not
happy
the federal government for many years
came out with the law saying that there
is what's called apportionment in uh
during the divorce that the um courts on
in the individuals are required to write
to the VA and they make the decision on
apportionments on how much money will
actually go to the dependents now
there's different stages in this here
whether you're retired because if you're
retired like myself uh then a certain
portion of my retirement go uh would go
to the ex-wife there or whatever same
thing uh vice versa disability in your
disability uh which is not a marital
asset is there's a certain portion in
there that is divided uh to the
apportionment that will go to dependence
but my main thing here is to make sure
that we correct the formula and tell the
judges to comply with federal law and
not to use their disability money
for
um you know child support and let the VA
decide on this per the federal law and
like I said you're probably going to get
some testimony today for male and female
onto a divorce and I know after being
married three times that sometimes
children are used as pawns and nobody's
ever happy what you know on how much
money that they get
so um you know and they always want more
and I don't blame them you know veterans
want to take care of their children
uh and that's very important especially
me as a father of seven children I
understand and paid my dues and educated
my children so I can understand where
some veterans are coming from and we do
have our five percent that they have to
fight with in order to make sure that
they support their children just like
anyone else but this hair is a
no-brainer here you know to make sure
that the state of New Hampshire complies
with the uh federal law and I'm going to
stop right there because you're going to
get more testimony from the veterans in
New Hampshire today some are probably
homeless living out of their cars and
other ones have gone through this air
and gone to the Supreme Court and they
can explain better to you than what I
can so therefore I'll stop right now and
I'll take whatever questions you have
Madam chair
thank you representative baldosaro so I
have a question could you kindly send to
the committee the federal lawyer talking
about
uh yes it's actually in the bill
um
the entire Federal expression
yeah what I can do is uh Sean bronstein
is going to be speaking uh he probably
has the federal law right there in front
of him I'm actually not at my home I'm
in another location uh and I could
probably try to search for it and send
it but I'm sure Sean has it right at his
fingertips okay thank you thank you I
brought this bill forward on behalf of
you know the many veterans that's the
reason right
uh representative petrigno
you gotta unmute please
thank you madam chair and thank you
representative for taking my question
you know I I believe that we all want to
support veterans and I think we all want
to support children in need you know and
when I look at this legislation it seems
that veterans and their children are
struggling over the same limited dollars
and personally I think that is a sad
commentary on how we treat veterans and
children in need do you know of any
other proposals or legislation out there
by which we can actually increase
benefits to Veterans rather than to take
from their dependent children
well it's this is a federal issue uh you
know the state has really has no law of
a silent on it and the federal law base
says you know it's not a marital asset I
wish there was a better answer there I
know we were fortunate in the last
president because it took over 40 years
to finally get uh veterans in New
Hampshire we don't have a full service
hospital to get
treated by the best doctors in the
community
you know and like myself I use Dana Faba
document and other operations that I've
had within the last nine months here in
cancer and throat operations so
you know it's a great question it's
something that we have to fight our two
senators in Congressman to push in the
federal law
okay thank you
are there any further questions for
representative balthazaro
saying none thank you very much
representative thank you madam chair
have a great day you too
up next is beyond
brookshaw
to speak in support I can give you two
minutes I know you asked for seven but
we've got a lot of people that want to
testify
are you there
okay
next is um attorney Mahoney
to speak in opposition
and give you two minutes
thank you very much good morning
um I I am speaking in opposition to this
bill
well I have nothing but complete
admiration for our veterans and I agree
with attorney long that they should or
attorney petrine I mean representative
Petrino that they should probably be
receiving better benefits than what they
are
the fact of the matter is the entire
family of a disabled veteran is impacted
by
their disability
and a veteran receives enhanced benefits
because it he or she has dependents
there is no
basis in any law that says that the
disabled veteran doesn't have an
obligation to support his family
or her family the
um
confusion I think sometimes arises and
it's important for the committee to
understand that there is a distinction
between treating disability veterans
disability benefits as an asset
and as a source of support
as an asset the law is very clear
disability benefits veterans disability
benefits are not to be included in the
marital estate when dividing assets at
the time of a divorce off limits no
question
but the law is also equally clear that
that is that disability benefit is a
financial resource to that disabled
veteran
if the disabled veteran is a low income
if that disability is the only financial
resource
he or she has then that is clearly taken
into account in the calculation of the
on the guidelines a very low income
individual has a maximum
um support obligation of fifty dollars a
month
however
many disabled veterans are able to work
um but they may not be working as much
as they would if they weren't disabled
that impact on on a disabled veteran
also impacts his or her family
and the veteran disability is there to
not only
provide financial support to the veteran
but also to his or her dependents that
is very clear and has been clearly
stated when this very issue came before
the United States Supreme Court in a
case of Rose versus Rose
and I can give you the site if you need
that I'll I can look that up for you but
there has been a clear
um
precedent in the law in the federal law
that veterans benefits
are available for the calculation of
that veterans uh this I have to remember
to say disabled veterans benefits not
just veterans benefits but disabled
veterans benefits are available for
calculation in determining a disabled
vets support to his or her family
so I urge the committee to
um not
pass this bill
thank you very much
thank you
um representative long has a question
thank you madam chair so attorney the um
so if if a disabled veteran was to get a
compensation and I'm looking at the
calculations here of twelve hundred
dollars for a child
um if this bill passed that compensation
wouldn't be included
correct okay thank you that's yeah I
just wanted to confirm that thank you
are there any further questions for
attorney Mahoney
thank you very much thank you for giving
me the time to talk to you today
good luck
thanks so much
up next is Jerica Angelini
okay you've got two minutes
okay thank you good morning
um
I'm the ex-wave of Sean bronstein and
it's my understanding that he is one of
the authors of the spell and I just
learned about this bill last week but it
appears that he's been working on it for
quite some time now unfortunately Sean
and I had a very lengthy and contentious
divorce process which took years to
complete it ended with him appealing all
the way to the U.S Supreme Court which
declined to review his appeal the
primary driver behind this appeal
process was because he vehemently did
not want to pay me the child support
that Family Court granted me I'm here
today to express to you my strong
concern in opposition to this bill and
it is my hope it will not be passed I
have nothing but great appreciation and
respect for all of our military men and
women especially our disabled veterans
and I feel that they are rightly
entitled to the many benefits and
programs that are offered to them in my
eyes the bill in question today does not
make sense child support is granted for
a reason so there's Equity between both
of the child's homes insinuating that
the ex of a disabled veteran should
forego child support despite being
granted to the ex from a judge feels
unethical for instance if if this bill
were to pass it is likely I would lose
my child support entirely which I rely
on to provide for my daughter who will
make up that difference in my situation
it has been explained to me I should
TANF money or other benefits granted by
the state which means the shortfall
created by not receiving child support
would become a burden of the taxpayers
and not the person who helped bring my
child into the world
in my case Sean receives a specific
benefit Social Security survivors
benefit from my daughter of about a
thousand dollars monthly and that money
is no longer split between the parents
when they divorce in New Hampshire
however when I apply for state benefits
through DHHS they include the entire
amount of that thousand dollars benefit
because they say it follows the child
despite the fact that it has already
been calculated in my child support
payment from from Sean this means that I
qualify for fewer benefits as it is with
passage of HB 317 it would mean none of
Sean's income would be considered when
calculating child support yet twelve
thousand dollars of income paid to him
for our daughter counts against me when
applying for benefits
think of how many people would be
impacted drastically by passing HB 317
and also think of who anyone who splits
custody with a disabled vet and makes
less annually than the vet would be
negatively impacted that means at a
minimum the most vulnerable would stand
to lose the most I would be one of those
people I have full-time steady work and
Sean's income as a disabled veteran is
more than double what mine is he lives
in the house that we bought together a
large home in a cul-de-sac neighborhood
and by contrast I live in a small second
floor two-bedroom apartment there are
already great disparities between our
daughters two homes without continued
child support the disparities would
increase further and be potentially
devastating for my daughter as I may not
be able to afford what little I have I
believe there may be other programs or
bills that would benefit disabled
veterans without encumbering the
taxpayers or hurting those of us single
parents trying to raise two small
children if us this bill has the ability
to potentially negatively impact
thousands of children in much the same
way as my daughter thank you very much
for your time today
thank you very much are there any
questions
seeing none thank you
up next is Patrick
Donegan
and give you two minutes
Mr uh thank you madam chair I will try
to be very very brief then
representative hold on hold on I wasn't
calling you
I was just asked to unmute
Patrick gone again
Matthew okay he's not here go ahead
representative Graham thank you madam
chair for the record I am representative
John Graham and I represent Hillsborough
district 7 which is the town of Bedford
as a military veteran and one who
receives uh disability compensation from
the VA I oppose this bill
let's begin by looking at what uh
veterans disability compensation is it
is a monetary payment for injuries
suffered as a result of military service
depending upon the severity the VA
assigns a
um a rating in 10 10 increments from 10
to 100 percent
each of these has a different monetary
value and in my written testimony I did
provide a break out of what those
um were at each of the levels
but at no matter which level the payment
is exempt from federal income tax
thus at a hundred percent level the
veteran will be receiving over three
thousand a month
and it is tax-free and at that level the
veteran is eligible to have all of his
medical expenses including Dental
provided by the VA
um
and they're showing at the tables at the
end
for each eligible child the veteran
receives an additional amount of money
to representative Long's comment earlier
on that one chart where it shows for
example twelve hundred dollars that is
not all just for the child it is part of
the overall package
I would also like to point out that
there's a problem in paragraph two of
the bill specifically a statement unless
the veteran has waived a portion of
retirement pay in order to receive such
compensation
this refers to an ongoing policy that
reduces a member's service member's
retirement pay dollar for dollar
if he receives the VA disability pay
thus my disability of 400 a month comes
directly out of my retirement pay
however the law was recently changed so
if you're 50 or more which are the
higher levels that we're talking about
um you receive both your military
retirement pay and the full compensation
from the VA
but what I'd like to stress here is that
um the higher the VA ratings we are
potentially talking thousands a month
and as a
veteran and as
um representative baldusaro said earlier
we all want to support our children I
think that we ought to continue along
the path
um that we currently have where it is
considered uh I know that one of the
previous speakers mentioned Roe Rose
versus Rose under the Supreme Court I
did provide you all with the synopsis of
that and I would ask that you read that
before making any judgments with that I
hope I kept it under two minutes Madam
chair and I went along but you know yeah
well are there any questions for
representative Graham representative
alchiller
um I actually I do not thank you very
much representative Graham um I do not
have a question for him I just wanted to
uh let you know I'm getting a message
from representative Horrigan that he's
in the waiting room and would like to
testify as well yep I'm I'm going down
the list thank you thank you
so up next we have John Jett
to speak in support Mr Jett you have two
minutes
you need to unmute please
see ya
Mr Jack can you unmute please
Mr Jett are you there
okay we'll come back to Mr Jett
on to Christopher Cianci
you don't see him I thought I saw him
see
each one I saw him before
was he was before wasn't he
don't see him now
okay so next we'll go to Claire Lord
I hope so
okay let me see Mr Jack can you unmute
yet
okay next will be representative
Horrigan
thank you very much Mr chair can you
hear me now
um
Madam chair yes I oh definitely not that
was like a
that was like the biggest misstatement
ever anyway thank you very much Madam
chair
um
and uh
actually miss Angelini and attorney
Mahoney and John Graham made a lot of
the same points I made in my uh written
testimony or they did a lot more
eloquently than I could um and just as
problems or even noticed this is an
exact repeat of HB 1716 which came up
last year was one of the first all
virtual bills the hearing executive
session took place entirely on Zoom but
it uh never got a floor vote you know
there's some strange stuff happen on the
floor but it probably could have been
and it would have just been an interim
study bill anyway and it was inspired by
a her case of Sean bronstein and Jessica
bronstein who's the same person as
Jessica Jerica Angelini who just heard
from a few minutes ago and I um
I could provide a copy of the court case
in case you you in case you uh in case
you need it so he he lost that case and
uh Miss Angelini well it's nobody ever
wins a family law case but she you know
she she was on the prevailing side
Supreme Court uh
and uh
whenever the facts we've already covered
the facts of the case um
Mr Brownstein and some of the other
Witnesses in the previous case uh put
some child support worksheets in the uh
permanent Bill files and um I I looked
at those I actually feel a bit
uncomfortable that
uh there's some identifying information
that wasn't reacted from all protected
from all the sheets and Mr Bronstein's
case he he blanked out his daughter's
name but not her
birth date but um that's something we'll
have to think about especially now that
the bill files are like more accessible
than they used to be
um and um he argued that his veterans
disabilities
benefits should have been left out of
the child support calculations I I moved
the opinion as is the Supreme Court and
others that um
they should be should be included in
fact the disability uh program uh
specifically supports not just the
veteran himself or herself and but um
uh the families as well and um
and also so like you know in child
support you are supporting a family
member you know you you and um
then there's Us in Boulder sorrow uh
let's well one more time about last time
but more so this time we already just
built victimizes veterans but actually
veterans are both sides of the child
support equation there's many uh
especially female veterans who are back
receiving child support and deserve to
receive uh child support and even though
veterans do have a higher incident of uh
mental health issues um
the uh
they don't necessarily uh
in other ways other ways they actually
do better than most members of society
simply because you know they're they're
we have a volunteer military with a you
know high standards for who who gets in
and then um and also military service
you learn a lot from that although I
should like and myself I'm either a
veteran nor a uh nor have I been through
a child custody case I want divorce I
went through we had no children or
anything that much to fight about but
um
so anyway I'm in opposition to Bill and
uh the federal law a question I believe
is 45
uh
45 CS CFR paragraph
302.56 and that's there's also reference
to that in the bill and also uh if you
get a copy of bronstein versus
Bronstein's decision that mentioned it
there they um the Supreme Court it was a
rather
they were they had it was a rather uh
scathing it's rather skating decision so
they cited many many precedents this is
a anyway the veterans disabilities
get back to the main point the veteran
disabilities
um our earnings and income so they are
something that the uh
parent you jump to wrap it up
representative okay so anyway I'm I'm
gonna post this bill I think the federal
law actually uh requires us to count
those uh disability benefits because it
says all earnings and income and
disabilities uh benefits our income and
also I think I probably forgot the
formerly statement record I'm president
Timothy Horrigan I represent Stratford
County district 6 Thurman Matt Berry and
I'm in opposition to this bill and I did
send in um it's in some written
testimony and I'd be happy to send in a
copy of the bronstein case in case you
don't get it from some other source and
so that's it I mean I'd be happy asking
any questions but you probably want to
uh move on and hear from the other
Witnesses so
are there any questions for
representative poor again
seeing none thank you very much
representative yeah thank you and it's
anticlimatic but thanks thank you
up next it will go to Christopher Cianci
hi everybody
um
my name is Christopher Cianci and um I
am a disabled veteran and I just think
this bill uh needs to be passed it's
important that it is passed uh veterans
uh who are disabled receive benefits and
um it's up to the VA uh what benefit
amount that may or may not be and
um they've issued the im9803 which is
the apportionment process
for state courts to follow and it's just
important that that process is followed
so that
um
benefits that veterans receive are
accurately distributed and that's what
that process has been set up for is for
um the benefits to go directly from the
VA to whatever beneficiary is receiving
the benefit and so I just think that
this bill is important to pass
and that's all I have to say today
thank you are there any questions for Mr
Cianci
all right see you then very much
okay Mr Cat are you able to unmute yet
because I see you there
okay next we'll go to Brenda town
who has requested three minutes
hi can you hear me
yes okay thank you very much
um I'm here today again just to speak in
support of this bill and my role as a
parent advocate
um I had my first face-to-face session
with parents of New Hampshire 40 parents
showed up and in the course of meeting
them all 20 of them I recognized were
homeless and of the homeless population
um 18 of them were veterans when I dug
into this issue what I found is that
they were disabled veterans and it had
their child support taken from their
disability pay which was the sole um uh
source of their income I want to say
that veterans do in fact uh want to
support their children and these
veterans did unfortunately the
compensation that the VA gives a veteran
is a relatively small versus the child
support calculation that the state of
New Hampshire uh grants for instance in
one case that I'm familiar with the the
state gave 39 a child for four children
sorry that was the Veterans
Administration gave that to the parent a
total of a hundred and thirty dollars
and the state removed twelve hundred
dollars from the veterans disability
leaving him incapable of supporting
himself with that being said there is a
very discreet process Associated or for
veterans uh disability to be granted to
the obligee parent and that is tied to
what the secretary of the veteran
administration has put in place it's per
USC 511 and what should happen is the
state of New Hampshire has no visibility
into the issues that a suffering veteran
is dealing with he could be dealing with
huge medical costs prescriptions all
kinds of other expenses in order to be
able to maintain his health because this
compensation is granted because of
injury
um what the Veterans Administration does
is it offers an apportionment process
and what we are asking the state of New
Hampshire to do is follow federal law it
is the federal law that a parent
approached the Veterans Administration
and follow the apportionment process at
which times the VA will allocate those
funds to the parent it is not in the
state's purview to issue These funds so
I just wanted to flag that to you guys I
know that USC 511 will be provided to
you and it is my hope that we have
Carson Tucker on the phone who is an
attorney who just won a Supreme Court
case in another state prevailing over
the fact that veterans disability
compensation should not be included in a
state's child support calculations thank
you very much
thank you are there any questions for
Miss town
seeing none thank you very much
Mr Jett are you available to unmute yet
all right up next
um is
Carson Tucker Mr Tucker I know you asked
for 30 minutes but I I can give you
eight minutes and then I have to recess
this hearing and we'll have to come back
another day that's fine can everybody
hear me okay
yes okay hi uh good morning or good
afternoon I'm actually in the United
Kingdom that's where I live in Cambridge
but um I did submit a written statement
and I would love for you um to be able
to read that I think it's extremely
important to clarify some of the
misconceptions about federal law for
example I'll go over one in particular
that has been a thorn in the side
um I've given you some background
information about myself as well I am a
veteran I'm not disabled um I was about
24 years in the military
and uh 27 and um I'm an attorney as well
as as was said before and and I was a
Jag officer
um for uh 12 years and as a Jag in the
Army uh the last stint of my military
career I was enlisted before that in the
Navy
um I sent a tremendous amount of
veterans downrange which meant I uh took
care of their legal Affairs uh advised
them and their families what would
happen to them if they did not come back
or if they did come back wounded and
injured and I can tell you that um I
sent thousands of veterans uh deployed
thousands of veterans and you know they
did not all come back and the ones that
did come back did not come back the same
as when they left and this has had an
enormous impact upon me and the work
that I have done in the last uh
essentially six or seven years for
disabled veterans it's uh uh it's
something that I have taken very
seriously and um I want to establish a
misconception Rose versus Rose is a 1987
opinion from the United state supreme
court which did state that the states
were free to consider veterans
disability pay even if the veteran is a
hundred percent disabled for purposes of
establishing a child support obligation
the year after Rose versus Rose in 1988
Congress established legislation called
the veterans judicial review act they
amended Provisions that were referred to
in Rose as uh allowing the United States
Supreme Court to hold that way
Congress
fundamentally changed the Paradigm for
the consideration by the states of
veterans disability pay for child
support and spousal support purposes and
the reason that that's so important to
understand it was in 1988 I have seen as
the previous speaker said firsthand the
states have spent the better part of 30
years
um I I I don't want to say ignoring but
um misunderstanding and misapplying
these Federal statutes that restrict and
limit the States from considering a very
specific amount of disability
compensation that's paid to veterans
uh in child support obligations and what
it does is it allows the states to count
a hundred percent of the veterans income
whether or not it's 100 disability or if
there are other sources it allows them
to take 100 of that disability
compensation and put it over in The
Ledger of available income uh earlier
someone asked whether there were
specific legal provisions and laws I
will give you those they are in the
statement 38 USC section 511
um removed concurrent jurisdiction from
the state courts to consider even the
question of whether or not these
benefits can be considered section 511
of title 38 of the United States code
actually states that the veterans the
Secretary of Veterans Affairs has the
exclusive final and conclusive
jurisdiction with respect to all
questions of law in fact concerning a
claim for benefits by both the veterans
and their dependent
um the reason that this bill is correct
is because it allows or I'm sorry it
defers to that exclusive jurisdiction of
the Veterans Administration the Veterans
Administration and the secretary can and
in some cases do a portion of part of
the veterans disability compensation and
allow that to be paid to the um to the
dependents in support obligations but it
it has to be the VA that does that
because they have the Appropriations
from Congress by virtue of the military
Powers Clauses in the Constitution which
is the source of this legislation and as
some of you may know when Congress
passes legislation pursuant to its
enumerated powers the supremacy clause
provides that that's legislation
preempts all state law that stands in
its way another misconception of rose
is that um the statement that states
have presumption
presumptions of authority and
jurisdiction over matters concerning
domestic and family law that was a
statement that was stated in Rose but in
fact every Supreme Court case before and
after Rose has rejected that proposition
and in fact Hillman versus Moretta which
is a 2015 case from the U.S Supreme
Court and Howell versus Howell which is
a 2017 case from the United States
Supreme Court which is the case that I
was the Amicus brief writer on I'm
admitted to the U.S Supreme Court for
the Veterans of Foreign Wars that was a
unanimous opinion agreeing with every
one of the propositions we posited
concerning the protection that federal
law provides for these particular
benefits okay
um and and the statement in Rose that's
been rejected is while State family and
family property law must do major damage
to clear and substantial Federal
interests before the supremacy clause
will demand that state law be overridden
the relative importance to the state of
its own law is not Material when there
is a conflict with a valid federal law
because the framers of our constitution
provided that federal law must Prevail
and specifically this is a quote from
the United States Supreme Court a state
divorce decree like other laws governing
the economic aspects of domestic
relations must give way to clearly
conflicting Federal enactments that
principle is but the necessary
consequence of the supremacy clause of
the national Constitution that case is
Ridgeway versus Ridgeway it's been
repeated in Hillman versus Mareta on
2015 case from the court and again in
Howell versus Howell the 2017 case now I
want to assure the committee that there
is provision in the law in federal law
for the payment to dependence of support
obligations ah
this bill HB 317 refers to that
provision it's 42 USC 659 H-1B
3 and 42 U.S 659 h1a25
those two Provisions explain clearly
when the states can and when they cannot
count as quote unquote remuneration for
employment which is income these
benefits the issue here and I think it's
a cultural issue as well as an economic
issue and it's an issue that relates to
the fact that we have been at War on one
sense or another for over 30 years
multiple theaters of operation
um significant injuries we have over 5
million disabled veterans in the United
States 70 percent of that number is
greater than 70 percent disabled and the
they're not retirees these are people
that go into the military spend four
five six seven years they get injured
and wounded too much to continue in that
career so they become disabled and
medically discharged we're not talking
yeah I'm I'm sorry to interrupt but we
have to stop now
um I'm gonna have to recess the is
public hearing to a future date and time
it will be noticed in the calendar those
who have not had the opportunity to
speak yet will have to sign up again
um and Mr Tucker I will put you down as
the first Speaker just be sure to
um sign up again okay thank you very
much and it's noticed in the calendar
all right
so I am recessing the public hearing on
House Bill 317 and we will be in recess
until 1 15.
foreign
yes thank you
people have to know I do have a laptop
and I just have to get it configured
enough so that I can use it Oh
no I got it
afraid of last week I got it right and
you know everything changed
all right on the other hand I figured to
come in for committee meetings
about two minutes all right
what part of the cell phone do you have
I have a TracFone okay
oh yeah look there's no cell phone
reception where I live either so uh no
point in having a fancy phone
together
but there are lots of good things about
it like mud season
ing
all right so I don't have representative
Testament
and who else would look very interesting
one more minute
oops
I'm just going to go on to clarify what
I did earlier
good afternoon everyone Thanks for
coming back
I just wanted to clarify before we start
the next hearing I I know I sounded a
little confused last time because I said
recess twice but we are going to we we
are recessing
um 317 to another date
okay and when I said recess I meant we
were recessing for lunch but 317 but
we'll be rescheduled to another date
um okay as will
um unfortunately
um House Bill 68 I only scheduled a half
an hour for it and it's going to take a
lot longer than that so I'm gonna have
to reschedule that one at 145. we'll get
through as many as we can and then we'll
have to then we'll have to be
rescheduled also
okay
so is everyone ready did everyone have
good lunch
good good okay
um
surf are you ready
yes okay all right so I'm gonna open
the public hearing on House Bill 68 and
I will follow up the Bill's sponsor
representative Dave testerman
Madam chair
I thought we have to do a roll call to
make sure that we're all present
yeah not after lunch
do we have to do that
Christina
no I can see that there is a quorum
present so we don't need to do that oh
okay
well thank you any anyways though
represent your way to have my back I
appreciate that
okay
so representative Testament
oh I uh this is Dave testerman I
represent uh two Wards of Franklin in
the town of Hill uh this is my third
term
I'm bringing a bill to you today hb68 is
a relatively straightforward uh it uh
you know it's about two sentences it
just changes the deaf one it adds a
definition to one of the cases for child
abuse
I don't care how parents want to dress
their kids how they want to address
their kids
things like that not my not my business
to get into is the bill says I'm just
talking about drugs and operations or
surgery
it's a little bit like you know cutting
off a finger a little boy points at you
because it represents a gun uh that's
not something you should do of course uh
a couple years ago we we banned a female
genital immutilation uh it's uh it's a
law now and of course we don't want to
be doing that in a case like this
uh using puberty blockers these are
hormones they're used to slow down the
puberty cycle or in fact sometimes uh
you know stop it all together it's not
really a healthy uh in many cases it has
long-term effects it ends up with
Suicidal Tendencies blood clots brittle
bones things like that
a few uh what would have been a year and
a half ago I talked to a person who had
uh gone the complete route he was very
unsatisfied with his life he decided to
change it and had a an operation and
took all the hormones and so on
the interesting thing he said was I
still had the same problems I did before
the same concerns and so on so it's
somewhat a pointless issue I know a lot
of people talk about it but it's really
somewhat nonsensical
uh okay yeah all I'm trying to do is
protect young kids by the time most
children are 20 to 25
they'll have decided whatever their
sexual preferences are are probably the
same ones they were born with it's
higher high percentage of that
and with that I'm open to questions
you
are there
any questions for representative
testerman
I have one
representative testerman do you have a
medical degree of any kind
I do not I'm an engineer
thank you
I guess that's oh representative the
Lander I have four children and 12
grandchildren so I know a little bit
about them
um thank you madam Madam chair
um representative
um testerman
are you
who would you propose
through these child abuse complaints
the same ones that do for all other
kinds of child abuse so you're referring
to diesel
sorry
so you're referring to dcyf yes
yeah
another one well please
are you aware of the case loads that
these caseworkers are currently dealing
with now
I am I and uh yeah this is a situation
that I think is important uh and it
should be uh should be taken care of by
dcyf that's no excuse for an easy wayf
not to do their job
and one more follow-up and one more
follow-up
and why sir do you feel like this should
be child abuse
well it clearly uh makes a physical
change either through drugs or through
surgery uh that just makes no sense to
do it yeah it's like I said earlier
would you cut off the index finger
because a little boy points it and uses
it again just doesn't make any sense
thank you
representative cross
hi representative testerman
um are you aware that when these
children go see doctors for
let's say surgery there are multiple
check boxes that they have to
hit before the doctor will do any type
of surgery
yes yes I am I've seen some of the
checklists
in this case because I'm only talking
about children you know you would have a
delay until age 18. you know there's
still a child at that point
representative
uh hello representative Testament my
question
um I have two quick questions
one is
um
there's a very different
um there's a there's a big difference
between a child that's six and wants a
sex change
and a child that's 16 or 17 that has
been through a lot more of the
counseling the medications and the
doctor's appointments with their parents
you're proposing that the parents get
uh criminally charged
with child abuse for that when they have
been working with doctors and probably
therapists along the way
up until the age of 18. if that's what
the abuse law calls for then that's what
we would have to do
so okay
Lester man my question then would be
what would happen to the
with that doctor be charged with child
abuse I'm not sure how that goes but it
it supposedly he was one of the
reporting people he would have to to
report it if he didn't report it he
would be guilty of child abuse
would he also be guilty of child abuse
if that child ended up committing
suicide because it didn't get the
treatment it needed
I think that is a case that is these
children are they do have a higher
suicide rate
having that kind of operation and that
kind of drugs won't reduce it
do you have statistics to back up those
facts I don't have them with me
could you get those to the committee
please I could yes you know
representative cross oh Madam chairwoman
I had another another follow-up question
I I apologize I'm sorry uh
representative cross just one minute
okay I'm sorry go ahead I'm sorry
representative Smith
um representative testerman if you are
saying that parents are criminally
responsible for
um having their child go through a
medical treatment like that could it not
be
um
like where does this end so could you
then charge a parent if their teenage
child has an abortion
um many would have would
possibly think that that is child abuse
I'm not talking about that I'm just
talking about this one specific
situation I wouldn't I know but you're
opening the door is what I'm saying I I
don't believe I am opening the door
I mean you
yeah
you have definitions of abuse is that
open the door for me
I mean I I just think it's a a
ludicrous comparison
okay thank you
representative cross
representative testerman do you have any
proof of any plastic surgeons performing
surgeries Top surgery any kind of
surgery changing their bodies in any way
before the age of 18 in New Hampshire
I do not I know of some cases
nationally but I don't know in New
Hampshire
there any further questions for
representative testerman
amen thank you
I'll be leaving
have a nice day
next up is
um Anya Tang
to speak in opposition
and
if
hi
hi go ahead we can hear you awesome
members of the committee my name is Anya
Tang
I'm a 17 year old trans person who goes
to school in New Hampshire
I oppose House Bill 68 because I believe
that denying me the health care I need
to feel safe and affirmed is abuse in
and of itself
under house bill 68's proposed changes I
would not be able to get the surgery nor
the hormone treatment I need for my
mental and physical health
when I was young whenever I looked in
the mirror I never ever saw a body or a
face that I could call mine or feel
comfortable with I have been trans for
as long as I've been able to think and
feel and move and I can confirm it's not
a phase and if it is 17 years is an
awfully long period of time to call a
phase
before I even knew what word to call
myself or what to call myself or what I
was I learned about transness through
someone called Leela Alcorn
her name was Lila Alcorn she committed
suicide on December 28 2014 because she
never received the gender affirming care
or support she needed
for months I followed eulogy's articles
and comments calling her by the wrong
name and the wrong pronoun the first
trans youth I ever knew I knew through
death why is this Joshua safer the
executive director at the center for
transgender medicine and surgery at New
York's Mount Sinai Hospital finds that
suicide attempt rates are as high as 40
among trans people who don't receive
medical treatment when they need it my
identity as a trans youth is and should
be a basic human right I should have the
freedom to be myself
the rest of the nation is working to
respect that already the Human Rights
Campaign binds that in 2010 just nine
percent of companies offered health care
benefits that cover gender affirming
surgical treatments now as of 2019 that
number has gone up to 83 percent
additionally Medicare the government
program for the elderly disabled has
already begun offering gender affirming
surgeries since 2014. what we need isn't
a step backwards is House Bill 68. we
need to keep on moving forward and that
means opposing bills like these
gender affirming care is health care and
House Bill 68 would make it illegal for
me as a minor to receive the health care
that affirms my identity
House Bill 68 would make it illegal for
my peers in the trans Community to feel
affirmed and to finally feel comfortable
and safe in their own bodies why do you
think 40 of trans people that aren't
able to receive medical treatment
attempts suicide when you deny this
access to a basic human right it tells
me and the other trans youth in our
community that there is never room for
us at the table or in your policy
deliberations
when you deny trans youth Healthcare and
push a bill that would call gender
affirming care abuse you are telling
your families that you are able to
intervene in interpersonal lives until
trans youth like me what our bodies are
feeling
this bill is a violation on basic
freedoms and my basic right to access
health care that is important for my
well-being as a trans youth trans
Healthcare is not female genital
mutilation puberty blockers are not
quote cutting off a little boy's finger
denying us the option is never a
pointless or nonsensical issue
representative testerman calls these
changes nonsensical representative
testerman is a CIS person he has never
felt gender dysphoria that's just the
the stress caused by a trans person
gender different from their sex assigned
by birth that comes with not getting the
health care you need as a trans youth he
lacks a medical degree of any kind he
has never known how awful and how
painful it feels when you don't feel at
home in your own body representative
Testament does not know what I feel he
will never ever access the experiences I
see and I feel as a trans youth I am
telling you as a trans youth to a post
House Bill 68 because representative
Testaments legislation is not informed
by the experiences nor the interest of
trans Youth and their families in mind
being able to transition as a trans
youth at home with the support of family
that can act as caretakers is the best
way to keep trans youth healthy in a
safe environment it is not abuse but
rather affirmation a Yale University
study found in 2020 that for Trans folks
that received gender affirming surgery
suicide attempts to drop to zero up to
three years after their surgery
furthermore a 2018 study published in
JMA Pediatrics corroborates out of 68
trans youth that receive gender
affirming surgery virtually none of them
experienced any regret up to five years
after their surgery in fact their
dysphoria was significantly reduced as a
result of the surgery
this type of Health Care works this type
of Health Care is what me and many other
trans youth need to continue having
access to
maintaining the ability for Trans youth
to receive gender affirming surgery and
treatment gives us the ability to
transition with our families before we
leave for college or before we leave for
the workplace both of which are
unfamiliar environments at least
separate trans kids from our support
systems that would otherwise help us
transition
doctors activists academics families and
trans youth have all provided countless
reasons and statistics and studies to
support maintaining access to gender
affirming surgery and treatment for
Trans youth none of it is ever abuse you
should join us in opposing house bill
68. opposing this bill is an opportunity
to Signal your support for the trans
community in New Hampshire and Across
the Nation because opposing this bill is
a recognition that access to healthcare
is a basic human right and a recognition
that families have the freedom to work
with their trans youth in deciding if
gender affirming care will help them
it is a recognition that access to
health care for Trans youth is not abuse
but affirmation it is recognition that
doctors families and most importantly
trans youth know what is best for them
not someone without a medical degree
opposing the spell signals to families
that they have the right to choose
gender firming surgery and treatment for
their trans Youth and as a step forward
that needs to happen along with this
rest of the nation
trans kids are just like any other kids
we hang out with their friends we help
out in our community and sometimes we
testify before State committees when
there's an issue we especially believe
in
treat us just like any other kid and
vote to maintain our access to health
care that we need access to as trans
youth thank you
thank you very much are there any
questions for Miss Payne
see you again thank you very much for
your testimony um did you send in
written testimony by the way
I did um I emailed it up to an hour
before the hearing great thank you
okay up next is
um Lindsay Collins who has asked for
five minutes
hello can you hear me
thank you um I won't need five minutes
but I will go ahead and get started my
name is Lindsay Collins and I'm a member
of the public a concerned parent and a
youth Outreach worker with trans youth I
oppose this bill because I believe it is
harmful to trans Youth and their
Guardians in the state of New Hampshire
it is not the state's place to make a
decision on whether or not someone
should receive gender affirming Medical
Care much less Define it as child abuse
this could be harmful for a trans youth
trans youth need our support and need to
be equitably included they are some of
the most vulnerable in our community and
this could in fact lead to worsening of
mental health issues I believe this bill
is a danger to trans youth in their
families and is very discriminatory as
well thank you for your time and
consideration
thank you so much did you send in
written testimony I did not but I can
forward it to the email
okay great thank you so much thank you
we have to cover one thing I need
um
representative
is he still here
I just need you to state that you're
here and if where you are and if you're
home alone and whatnot
I joined the uh the hearing at 11
o'clock this morning I am home alone in
my office great thank you so much you're
welcome thank you
okay up next is Allison Brielle
who has asked for five minutes
so Allison you can go ahead
Allison
you can go ahead
[Music]
I think it says click to unmute
low system resources may affect your um
okay
um
all right give me one second
Allison Brielle can you hear me
it looks like you're unmuted
and the members of the committee hear me
yes okay
now I don't know
what's going on
so I'm checking what my research
all right so can you go out and come
back in Allison and I'll I'll call you
when you get back in
and I'll go to the next person if that
correct Christina
yes I see that she's unmuted but it
looks like we're not able to hear so
we'll see if she can get back in okay
so why don't we go to Karina
Torres
oh she's not on
okay
how about Timothy turge
not here
today
Valerie Murphy
um
[Music]
Kelsey Wilson
description
okay Christine we're gonna pull you up
to go
hello hi can you hear me yes thank you
hi
um
dear members of the House committee on
children and family law
my name is Dr Christine R snow
I am a pediatrician and the vice
president of the New Hampshire Pediatric
Society which is the state chapter of
the American Academy of Pediatrics which
represents 242 pediatricians in New
Hampshire
my testimony is on behalf of that
organization as well as the New
Hampshire Medical Society which
represents more than 2 200 Physicians
Medical students and medical residents
in New Hampshire
we strongly urge you to vote no on House
Bill 68 which would cause incredible
harm to the health and well-being of
transgender youth in New Hampshire
it can be hard to understand what it is
like to have a transgender child
especially if you've never met someone
who is transgender
parents of transgender children
like most parents simply want to do what
is best for their child
in addition to harming transgender youth
this bill would directly interfere in
the physician patient family
relationship and harm pediatricians and
other medical professionals who provide
comprehensive evidence-based care for
transgender youth
medical professionals not politicians
should decide what medical care is in
the best interest of a patient in
conjunction with the patient and their
family
1.8 of Youth identify as transgender
and a further 1.6 percent are
questioning or gender diverse
this is not an easy path for many
children and teenagers around half of
these children consider suicide and the
third attempt it
we know that if youth are provided with
appropriate gender affirming care the
risk of suicide Falls dramatically and
transgender people have every
opportunity to live their life lives in
good health
medical care for transgender youth is
evidence-based and has proven
effectiveness
guidelines for appropriate treatment are
carefully developed and endorsed by the
American I'm sorry I apologize
by the American Academy of Pediatrics
the American College of obstetrics and
gynecology
the Pediatric endocrine endocrine
Society the American College of
Physicians the world professional
association for Chan transgender health
and the American Psychological
Association
Medicaid and major insurance companies
in New Hampshire cover gender affirming
care in fact until very recently the HHS
office of civil rights required coverage
from all insurers and these rules will
likely be reinstated
these medical guidelines provide for the
evaluation of children with gender
diversity or gender dysphoria
some of these patients identify as
transgender
before puberty there is no medical or
surgical treatment that is used at all
guidelines emphasize supporting children
as they express themselves treatment for
these children can include letting them
select the clothing they prefer getting
a new haircut or using a different name
this is called socially transitioning
and this measure alone has been shown to
decrease suicide rates
children with gender dysphoria undergo
detailed repeated psychological and
medical evaluation with the
participation and consent of their
parents
only after the onset of puberty is
medical treatment ever used and only in
some patients
treatment with medications to
temporarily suppress puberty is
reversible and allows the patient time
with their ongoing medical supervision
of their doctor to explore their gender
identity before committing to a
treatment path
these puberty suppressing medications
are commonly used for other conditions
such as early puberty and prostate
conditions in men and their safety is
well established later teenagers can
elect to receive hormonal therapy if it
is indicated generally after the age of
16 and after living in their authentic
gender for some time
fewer than one quarter of transgender
patients ever have surgical procedures
and these are generally recommended
after age 18.
this bill would make providing
evidence-based Medical Care according to
nationally recognized medical standards
of practice a crime
providing patient care that has helped
rather than harms is our duty according
to our Oaths as doctors this bill sets a
dangerous precedent and puts politics
rather than medical expertise ahead of
our patients health
this bill is an extreme attack on
transgender youth in New Hampshire and
will criminalize access to
evidence-based medical care for this
vulnerable population by all standards
this bill is also an egregious attack on
pediatricians and other medical
professionals ability to provide
evidence-based Medical Care
I urge you to vote no on House Bill 68.
thank you very much for your time
thank you very much are there any
questions for
um Miss arsenau
seeing none
thank you very much
now I'd like to go back to Allison for
y'all if I see her in the
waiting room so we will have her
um
Allison you would ask for five minutes
so I'm going to ask you to keep it to
the five minutes okay did you get her
can you hear me now yeah yes oh
wonderful keep it to the five minutes
that you requested though because and I
won't even need that much because I feel
like all these speakers have already
said much of what I wanted to sing
especially the first Speaker I applaud
that individual so much such passion and
knowing knowing themselves so well
um I am speaking as a parent of a
transgendered son as well as a nurse and
a future nurse practitioner
what I have seen
is the psychological damage that can
happen from somebody who is not allowed
to be themselves and a bill like this
would destroy my son even more he
um has self-mutilated he has
contemplated suicide and according to
different research out there over half
over 50 percent of transgender youth
either contemplate or attempt suicide
when they don't have appropriate
treatment right now my son is on a
hormone blocker this is reversible it
does not do any damage to him all it's
doing is stopping him from getting a
period which is very traumatic
soon hopefully he'll be starting
testosterone which has made him so happy
I can't even explain that much and I
really wish that representative
testerman could be here to hear these
things
I'm happy that he has kids and that he's
never had to experience the hardship of
a child wanting to kill themselves
and maybe if he had he'd have a slight
bit of empathy for this but I'm pleading
with this house to not pass this to vote
no and to show all the youth in our
state and in our country that we want
the best for them that we love them and
that we support them thank you
thank you are there any questions for
Mysterio
okay saying none thank you very much
have a great day
so unfortunately I am going to have to
recess this recording because
there were 69 people who
um signed up in advance for this to
testify on this
um bill and we just don't have the time
for it today so I'm gonna have to
um recess this to a letter later date
and time to be noticed those that have
not had the opportunity to testify will
need to go back on the general Court's
website and and sign up again or when we
do it
um
I'm sorry I never imagined there'd be
over 70 people because this is they're
still people with their hands up so um
I'm going to have to recess this hearing
and we will take it up to not next week
but the week after I'll get a date and
time and it'll be noticed
okay thank you very much sorry
hey and then next up is
um I'm gonna open the public hearing on
House Bill
60.
and I'm going to call on
um representative lebeck this is your
bill correct
hello can you hear me
my name is representative okay my name
is representative Cassandra Levesque
good afternoon
Madam and honorable members of the
committee thank you for allowing me to
speak on behalf of hb60
with this bill we hope
to rage for an in-child marriage in
Hampshire why am I determined to end
child marriage the answer is simple
marriage before age 18
can have lifelong impacts on people's
lives undermining their health and
education economic opportunities and
increasing their
risk of experiencing violence
for the past five years I've worked to
raise awareness and attempted to end
child marriage I have talked with
survivors
this if there's history held their hands
and cried with them I have made
connections and partnered with
organizations who work on their
behalf and I am beyond pleased that so
many are here with us today
we also have survivors here with us some
are ready to share their
history some are not and are just
watching the proceedings
we also have representatives from some
of the preeminent organizations on the
foref this campaign leading with
research data and experience in the
field they are here to help the spell
Miss and provide a sustained information
that should answer any remaining doubts
that the marriage age floor needs to be
raised
the hardest part of today is going to be
setting aside what you think you and
listen to the facts and data being
presented it's easy to get comfortable
with what we think is the right way of
things but times change data is gathered
if we move forward
sometimes we have to leave something
damaging in the past and move on to a
better future
one that empowers people instead of
harming them in the past I have shared
the story of my grandmother's Agnes and
Fanny but I want to continue Fannie's
story today
we know that child marriage has
Generations
as a reminder Fanning was 16 when she
married a 49 year old man Finney's
husband was an alcoholic and was
verbally and emotionally abusive
Finney's daughter Bertha when she
married married a man who would become
an alcoholic he was brutal with her and
their marriage ended in divorce
Arthur had four Sons her eldest son
would become an alcoholic whose own
marriage ended in divorce his children
fight addiction to this day
her second son abused drugs alcohol and
was bipolar
her third son abused drugs alcohol and
his marriage ended in divorce
his own struggle with addiction to drugs
and alcohol mental illness and have a
history of having abusives failed or
toxic relationships
recently reconnected with one of my
cousins she was married as a teenager
and her husband was physically mentally
abusive
she got into drugs her marriage ended
divorce and she is working to move on
to a healthier life for her and her
daughters
child brides are neither physically nor
emotion to become wives and mothers they
face more risk of experiencing dangerous
complications in pregnancy and
childbirth
Contracting HIV and a and suffering
domestic violence
with little access to education and
economic opportunities they and their
families are likely to live in poverty
gender after generation of my family has
been affected by child marriage
going to college is still very rare
currents in our family most of the side
work
for paying jobs and live right along the
federal poverty line
child marriage is Insidious and it
affects generational
some people feel that 16 and 17 year old
children know what love is and fully
understand what they are potentially
getting themselves into however I have
heard from many victims who disagree
with this and they have shared their
stories with me their voices will
forever echo in my heart and in my mind
a few examples of what I have been told
by victims of child marriage are my
husband put a dog collar around my neck
trust me up on the floor in front of my
parents just to prove to them that he
can control me
another my husband was a monster
another I was alone my husband was
deployed Germany and I had a high risk
pregnancy my parents flew my sister into
California to come and drive me across
country so that my family could help me
with the birth of my son
husband did not see his son until he was
19 months old they never bonded
another I was 16 and I wanted to escape
an abusive living situation and myself
in I married a sailor and when he came
back from his deployment in Hawaii he
used to verbally assault me and tell me
of all the other women he had been with
my self-esteem and tried to control me I
left the marriage with my infant
daughter
as you will know about here today many
children find themselves in a marriage
situation that is much larger problem
than they thought possible
there is a significant difference
between a 16 or 17 year old even one who
is exceptional
and an 18 year old the 18 year old has
reached the age of majority in New
Hampshire
this is crucial when we were talking
about marriage a serious legal Act
to enter into any contract you have to
have the legal capacity to give consent
to give legal valid consent a person
possess the cognitive abilities to
understand the basic nature of the
marital obligation into voluntary agree
to marry
to sustain modern marriage a person must
possess core aspects of Psychosocial
maturity and other abilities
while children and adolescents may have
attained the former capabilities by mid
adolescents aged 15 or 16. they will not
attain the latter psychosocial maturity
until late adolescence or emerging
adulthood in the early 20s
children do not have the right to marry
the marriage age has already been set at
18. with hb60 we are powering for
ensuring that they wait until they can
decide on their own as legal adults
whether and whom to marry
child marriage has no redeemed quality
period it offers no benefit to children
that cannot and should not be found
elsewhere and it brings countless
serious harms and risks
we do not allow exceptions to think
smoking or driving age
we set those ages based on when people
can engage safely in those activities we
should not do the same with marriage
agent marriage has for decades been the
strongest and most unequivocal predictor
of marital failure
the likelihood of divorce nears 80
percent for those who marry in the mid
adolescence then drop steadily delaying
marriage until the mid-20s reduces one's
likelihood a divorce to 30 percent
women who married at age 21 or younger
experience worse mental and physical
health attain less education and earn
lower wages than those who marry later
I've also been approached by people who
ask but what if a girl is pregnant in
response we have to keep in mind that
New Hampshire ranks number 49 out of 50
states for having the lowest teen
pregnancy numbers in the country
contrary to what U.S policy makers used
to believe pregnant teenage who stay
single actually have better long-term
outcomes than those who marry teenage
mothers in the US who married then
divorced are more likely to suffer
economic deprivation and instability
than teenage mothers who stay single
we as lawmakers have an obligation to
our citizens to lead them on the path of
success
New Hampshire has made sure that the
tools and power of these girls are
available they can access insurance
through New Hampshire Medicaid services
are available start smart programs
Community Action Partnerships can help
with their services of child care home
visits and Supportive Services
girls can get the parental care they
need through a variety of sources
located throughout the state they can
get rides to the care provider in 2021 I
think that pregnant teen is on their own
is ridiculous to outdated notion
marriage should not be encouraged just
because it's viewed as solution to a
problem I need to see exceptions to the
marriage age have been used to cover up
rape and to force girls to marry the
rapists marriage license data obtained
from across the U.S shows the number of
child Reapers recently were hand in
marriage licenses instead of prison
sentences
if New Hampshire creates a pregnancy
exception with other states move into
the in the option opposite direction New
Hampshire can easily become a
destination wedding site where parents
take their daughters who have been raped
to force them into marriage that is not
what we want New Hampshire to be known
as
the New Hampshire US state sorry the U.S
state Department
has called marriage before the age of 18
a human's rights abuse humans have the
right to education yet we know girls who
married before 19 or 50 percent more
likely than unmarried girls to drop out
of school and four times less likely to
complete College we also have the right
to live our lives free from violence we
have the right to employment freedom of
movement and the right to consensual
marriage child marriage denies many of
the victims those rights
according to the United Nations
conventions of the child rights the
child is defined as a human being below
the age of 18. in all actions concerning
children whether undertaken by public or
social welfare institutions courts of
Law and Ministry of authorities or
legislative bodies the best interests of
the child shall be a primary
consideration
according to Article 19 States parties
shall take all appropriate legislative
Administration social and educational
measures to protect from all forms of
physical or mental violence injury or
abuse neglect or negligent treatment
maltreatment or exploitation including
sexual abuse while in the care of
parents legal guardians or any person
who has the care of the child
we cannot say we're acting in the
inserts of the child when study show the
devastating long-lasting effects that
marriage before 18 has on life it
shatters the health education and
economic opportunities and increases the
risk of experiencing violence how much
longer will we wait before it's time to
stop this practice how many of our
victims will there be how more relief
destroyed the time to end child marriage
is not in the future the time is now
thank you for allowing me to introduce
hb60 today and I will answer questions
as I can
are there any questions for
representative lebeck
all right thank you very much
so up next I'm going to call
Representative
um mayor bed walls
all right I'm here can you hear me yes
great thank you so much for the record
my name is Mary Beth walls I am the
representative for Merrimack County
District number uh 23 which is the towns
of Bowen Dunbarton I'm in my seventh
term and for purpose of this testimony I
want to point out that I'm a lawyer
who's actually currently certified in
four jurisdictions to practice because
the main point of my testimony today and
and there are others that are going to
address other issues but mine is to
address some of the legal consequences
facing New Hampshire in this bill
so I'd like to start with pointing out
that under our current law our current
marriage laws in New Hampshire are
unconstitutional
and they are unconstitutional because we
require people going into a same-sex
marriage to be 18 years old to be
married for a heterosexual marriage the
requirement is only 16. that is clearly
an unconstitutional discrepancy here in
New Hampshire and passing this law and
raising everybody to the age of 18 would
fix that unconstitutional discrepancy
so we are as we sit here today in
serious danger of being sued over this
um I'm frankly surprised it hasn't
happened yet but I wanted to start out
with what perhaps is the most
significant legal problem with our
current laws and that is the
unconstitutionality
um many of you have heard me speak
before we have addressed this a number
of times in committee over the last few
years and one of the things that we did
in committee was we raised the burden of
proof and marriage
so for a minor child to get married
today they need to go and get a judge's
approval in a New Hampshire Court
and that standard before was the lowest
possible standard and we raised that
standard to the mid-level standard of
clear and convincing evidence
so now when a child goes to court the
judge has to find by a standard of clear
and convincing evidence which is about a
75 or 80 percent standard that it is in
the best interest of the child to
approve that marriage
so our Hope was that this would drop the
number of child marriages in New
Hampshire
we passed the law in 2018 effectively
the beginning of 2019 it's now been in
effect two years while I don't have the
data on child marriages in 2020 I do
have them in 2019 and the marriage rate
is unchanged
so it unfortunately did not drop the
rate of child marriage at all in this
state
I will tell you there's been some sort
of natural drop I've got the data from
2009. and from 2000 to about 2011 we had
double digit number of kids anywhere
from you know 12 to 25 who were getting
married in the state
since then it has dropped and from 2012
on it's been in the single digits and
last year uh for the last year I have
data which is 2019 there were five child
marriages
the vast majority of them 85 percent of
them involve a woman or a young girl
actually being married to a man
um and while now many of them are
similar ages there's still a third of
them that are marrying people who are
significantly older than they are
so the courts are still rubber stamping
this and that causes some concern
um
I'd also like to talk about
um a little bit legally about how we
treat children under the law
um there is extensive uh evidence out
there that many of you are aware of
about the physical or lack of physical
and emotional maturity of children
and we have recognized that in the law
you have to be 18 to vote you have to be
18 to sign a contract
to sign a lease to open a bank account
to buy a house
to buy a car
um at 16 and 17 you cannot smoke
you cannot drop out of school
at 16 you cannot enlist in the military
um you are still subject at 16 and 17 to
the delinquency laws in our state
and when a child goes to toast
themselves at a wedding when it's a
child marriage they can't do that
because they're not old enough to drink
across the board we recognize 16 and 17
year olds as children
and by failing to recognize them here
we are uh making a major mistake
we know that children who go into
marriage are eighty percent of those
marriages are likely to end in divorce
that means if the five children that we
know that were married in 2019 four of
them are probably already divorced
because most of those divorces happen
within the first year
we know that the education dropout rate
is much higher we know that this leads
to a lifetime of poverty for those we
know that this poverty extends into
multi-generational as it did in Cassie's
family
we need to recognize that 16 and 17 year
olds are still children when it comes to
marriage
we need to pass House Bill 60 and we
need to fix this unconstitutionality in
our law
and I'm prepared to take any questions
thank you representative walls I have a
couple of quick questions
um can you refresh my memory when the
last change in statute went into effect
I put I pulled statutes this morning and
it looks like the last amendment was
done in 2019 the last that I could see
when it went into effect
I think the first of the year I think it
was the one that changed the burden of
proof
I'm not 100 sure the way the laws are
the statutes are presented in the rsas
it's not immediately apparent you can
see the date the last year of change but
you can't exactly see what the change is
but I was hunting through old bills on
our website today and I from what I can
see that's the most recent change
okay thank you and um just for one
regarding emancipation didn't we just
change the Emancipation statute
um
two years ago was it I think that was
about I did not look at the Emancipation
statutes this morning I'm sorry but I
think it was the same year I do think
that it was an 18 that we changed it and
probably went into effect in 19.
okay thank you I'm gonna have the
committee researcher send us the
Emancipation patient statute and um the
current marriage statute and to also
find out the exact date that that went
into effect
well the the marriage statute I can tell
you because I did find it and it was
January 1st 2019 it was signed in 18 and
went into effect in 19. I suspect the
Emancipation is the same but if they
look at the bills that were in 2018
you're going to find that's where those
bills were
okay thank you
are there any further questions for
representative walls representative
Belanger
the vice chair can go first okay
thank you
um representative walls walls excuse me
um of the list that you named when you
talked about being able to smoke or
um sign up for the military or um of
that list how many of those are you
aware of that you need parental approval
to be involved in
because correct me if I'm wrong you can
sign up for the military under the age
of 18 if a parent does sign
um for you
representative Belanger I wondered that
so I researched it this morning and
honestly I'm not an expert on it and
there are witnesses Beyond me that know
more than I do I know they're going to
testify but what I found when I was
Googling it is that you can enlist at
17.
um it did not appear that we can still
enlist at 16 but it does the they did
say you can enlist at 17 when I was
trying to research that
follow up
so just of the list that you named off
can you give me an exit can you give me
any others that would need parental
approval
well I'm sure with opening a bank
account you could open it jointly with
parents it's not quite approval I'm sure
on buying a house a parent or a car a
parent could co-sign a loan again that's
not approval that's really them putting
themselves out there at the same time
um
I can't see anything else in here where
you need parental approval
thank you
representative DeSimone
thank you question representative walls
um can you tell me what constitutional
article talks about safe gender marriage
well nothing specifically addresses same
gender marriage what IT addresses is
we're talking about the equal protection
clause and so it's it's really the 14th
Amendment and when you look at the 14th
Amendment the equal protection Clause
says that you've got to treat people in
a similar way similarly situated people
in a similar way
I see thank you you're welcome
so representative walls I just have one
more question because I I'm going to get
the statute and look it over but I could
have sworn that we amended the marriage
bill so that we wouldn't run into that
problem
I I thought we included same-sex
marriage
in that bill am I wrong I I did not find
it when I was researching it that and
you know Kim this is my seventh term
I've been doing this a long time I don't
recall but I when I was looking it up I
did not find that you could be correct
on that
um but honestly my recollection was not
the same as yours
yeah but my recollection isn't that good
so
okay are there any further questions for
representative walls
all right saying that you've been saying
none thank you very much representative
thank you
okay and up next we're going to take our
representative Al chiller
I'm sorry
thank you very much Madam chair I
unmuted ahead of time this time so
um thank you committee members for your
time and attention to this really
important matter marriage is a contract
people in New Hampshire cannot enter
into legal contracts before they reach
the age of majority which is 18. it's
the threshold of adulthood as recognized
in law and I submit to the committee
that the people on in New Hampshire
under the age of majority who must seek
parental and judicial approval to enter
into a contract which they may not exit
until they actually reach the age of
majority is a manifestation of coercive
control
coercive control creates an unequal
power dynamic in a relationship it's a
form of domestic abuse and intimate
partner violence it describes a pattern
of behaviors a perpetrator uses to gain
control and power by eroding a person's
autonomy and self-esteem and this
includes acts of intimidation threats
and humiliation the younger the
Adolescent the more likely it is that if
they are sexually active they have
experienced coercive sex this is the
core understanding that underlies our
statutory rape laws and coercion is one
of the three warning signs of the
presence of human trafficking according
to the research conducted by the tourey
Justice Center
nationally girls and young women ages 16
to 24
experience the highest rates of intimate
partner violence among all such victims
and girls aged 16 to 19 face
victimization rates almost triple the
national average yet in Most states like
New Hampshire while girls ages 16 to 17
make up the vast majority of children
who are being married off they are least
protected by minimum marriage age laws
the United States Department the U.S
state department has devoted an entire
page on their website to this issue and
they recognize marrying children off
before the age of 18 as a human rights
abuse additionally the United States
citizenship and Immigration Services has
devoted an entire section of their
website to this phenomenon of forced
marriage and marrying children under the
age of majority off
in the USA 26 percent of women and 15
percent of men who were victims of
contact sexual violence physical
violence or stalking by an intimate
partner in their lifetime first
experience these are other forms of
Violence by that partner before the age
of 18. choosing a partner is a major
decision one that should be made freely
and without fear or coercion it is a
contract that one should be able to
enter into and exit out of without
age-based penalties or thresholds the
United States without age-based
penalties and a threshold entrance of
18. the United Nations population fund
released a report in 2020 entitled
against my will that unequivocally
States existing laws against child
marriage should be enforced especially
when girls at risk of child marriage or
who are already married seek protection
and Justice and where it is not yet the
case the legal age of marriage should be
raised to 18 without exceptions
in the U.S 200 000 children under the
age of 18 were married off between the
ages between the year 2000 and 2015. PBS
Frontline dug into that number and
discovered that more than 80 percent of
those children who were married off were
married off to somewhat substantially
older than them
people are not a commodity to be traded
they are not objects to be coveted nor
are they burdens to be discarded raising
the floor the entrance into the contract
of marriage to be 18 years old for all
New Hampshire citizens will be a
meaningful step in curbing the violence
presence with the coercive control of
narrowing off minors I thank you for
your time and attention my testimony has
been submitted to the Child and Family
Law email
thank you very much thank you next is
going to be representative grassy
can you hear me
yes okay thank you very much Madam
chairperson much of what my testimony
should be very brief because much of it
has already been stated I think one of
the important things to note right off
the fact is that the U.S state
department and you've heard this has
called child marriage human rights abuse
by the way for the record my name is
Chuck representative Chuck rassey from
Stratford 11 which is Rochester New
Hampshire
when it's when is it when a child is
married off they are 50 50 more likely
to drop out of high school
they are four times less likely to
attend college
and they are less likely to return to
school after childbirth
than mothers who are not married off
and that's important those that are not
married tend to keep their family
relationships
and they tend to go back to school
because of the support facilities that
they have amongst their family which
they do not get if they are out of the
family and married off
they tend to be lifelong wage earners
because of their lack of Education
being like long wage low wage earners
they earn 30 percent will live their
entire life in po poverty and this is
something that is multi-generational as
well so it isn't just the one single
person the young girl or young boy who
marries at a very young age who is in
poverty but they tend to have more
further Generations in that situation
married teens are 40 more likely to give
birth to a second child within 24 months
and they are three times more likely to
have at least five children
when we look at the rates of welfare in
our country and within our state a lot
of times we look and we look down on a
family that has a number of children
they have a lot of children well this is
a rate because they probably were
married at a very young age
did not attend did not finish school
have lived in poverty and know nothing
else about that being a mother who is on
Welfare
lastly they have a shockingly high
divorce rate of almost 80 percent
just one other thing that I would want
to address I had a chance to talk to
someone in the National Guard in the U.S
who had been in the Army and he advises
uh he is currently in the Army's first
sergeant in the in the National Guard
and he advises new recruits and one of
the questions he has a lot of times is
my girlfriend is pregnant is there a
problem here we aren't married
and he says have no fear you are covered
if you name her as a dependent the child
is a dependent they are covered under
the military benefits programs so that's
not an issue I know people have brought
it up in the past and throughout the
years that we've talked about this bill
that's one of the big things is that oh
the young boy who's going off to war or
going off to the military has got his
girlfriend home and he needs to marry
her before he leaves so she won't get
the benefits it's not true
Madam chairman I'll be happy to answer
any questions
thank you very much are there any
questions for representative Grassi
representative Belanger uh thank you
madam chair and thank you representative
grassy for taking my question uh my
question to you sir is
when you refer to quote married off
unquote can you define what you mean by
that
in other words in this situation you
have parents who are agreeing or signing
off to basically
transfer ownership of that young lady or
young boy to their spouse and in many
cases a young girl who is with a man
that is much older uh it's a way to get
people out of get a girl out of their
family uh in some cases it's uh it's
it's it's not right
um a lot of times you know some of these
young girls they're in love
and particularly if the boy is going off
into the military or
um these marriages don't last a long
time they end up on their own so when I
say married off I think it's important
to look at it that way they're not
consenting to a the parents aren't
consenting to a marriage they could wait
till 18 if they wanted to do that what
they're doing is they're basically
removing their daughter from their
family
just for clarification
my husband in no way owns me never has
never will neither does my first husband
that I got married with at 19.
okay just because I got married young
does not mean I was owned by someone
are there any further questions for
representative grassy a follow-up
manager follow-up representative
Belanger
I'm 26 years old I'm married too I've
been with my wife since she was 17 and I
was 18. I do not own my wife for the
record I agree with you madam chair
um can you give me a statistic of Mr
grassy
um in regards to
that
sorry I lost it my apologies
that literally just went out the door
thank you madam chair
um so representative grassy
just need clarification on uh
married married out I understand what
you're saying so we're talking about
16 15 year olds that I'm marrieding 40
year olds or 35 year olds not a 17 year
old married and an 18 year old or a 19
year old Marion in a 25 year old
a 17 year old marrying a 25 year old and
and I think that the the thing you're
looking at as well is when I say
ownership that young girl at 16 years
old cannot engine a contract
she has to have her husband do those
things for her
so so in a sense that that is an
accurate a statement okay so uh follow
up Madam chair
sure so the um
the ownership in your mind is if I'm in
if I'm underage and the uh
and I'm into a contract that I can't get
out of until I'm
at age
uh that is what you're forming has
ownership
yeah it was probably a poor term to use
in a sense but the thing is is yes many
girls who get stuck in that situation
feel they have no way out
and you know when you're looking at that
that they have no way out it makes it
very very difficult
are there any other
um
I have a question I do believe that when
we passed the Emancipation The Limited
emancipation a few years ago we did
include
marriage so that I believe we included
it so that they could contract an
attorney to get out of the marriage and
so that they could um open their own
bank account would you believe that
I would
thanks
representative Litchfield you have a
question
thank you madam chair actually I believe
that you've just answered it um but if I
could just repeat it and you clarify my
question was basically is so is the
bottom line concern on this bill not
necessarily the age of mad marriage but
rather the opportunity to dissolve the
union if necessary am I hearing that
correctly no no it is the age of
marriage specifically it is not the
right to dissolve the marriage but to
someone who is 16 or 17 uh getting into
that situation statistically statistics
have proven that they have a much they
have it much harder in life even if they
can dissolve the marriage uh when you're
married at 16 or 17 a lot of that is
beyond
um your ability to understand what's
going on you're in a bad City you may be
in a bad situation you may be hopefully
in a good situation eighty percent of
them turn out not to be good situations
and they end up in divorce
so it's that's not it it's not being
able to get out of the situation they
shouldn't be put into into the situation
where they are allowed to get themselves
into that kind of situation prior to
Turning 18. I mean I know 18 and 19 year
old boys and girls that shouldn't be
married as well but our age or majority
is 18.
so
thank you are there any further
questions for representative grassy
seeing none thank you very much thank
you
up next will be now yeah
I'm in and I'm sorry if I did not do
your name Justice
he's not there
okay Don Tyree
John Tyree if you unmute there you go
hi there thank you can you hear me
um thank you for allowing me the space
to testify again my name is Don Tyree
and I'm a member of the public I'm a
Survivor of child marriage and I'm here
to support hb60 in ending child marriage
it's never in the best interest for a
child to marry I was forced into
marriage at 13 years old
and while I can relate that that's much
younger than what we're talking about
today I can tell you that a 17 year old
is at risk and it has devastating
repercussions
my marriage was more about abuse control
and manipulation Than Love
I was married to my rapist after he got
me pregnant he had been sexually abusing
me for two years
I was powerless over my body with no
rights not one adult in my life talked
to me about birth control so 13 months
later I had my second child at 15 years
old
there's no equality in America in a
child marriage even a 17 year old to a
19 year old there is no equality it
started off without equality
I couldn't register myself for school at
15 years old and I couldn't register
myself for school at 17 years old when I
left him I left at 16 years old and when
I went to register myself back into high
school at 17 years old I was told that I
needed my parents and when I when I
mentioned that I was divorced and wanted
to enroll myself in school I was told
that I needed my ex-husband to come and
enroll me
I couldn't rent a hotel room when I
wanted to leave with my new with my two
children
I was turned away from shelters and
Social Services advised me to go back to
my parents
my my ex-husband reported me as a
runaway and law enforcement threatened
to take me back to my ripe rapist
we live below the poverty line for
probably a decade
we lived without toilet paper or shampoo
and we often lived without electricity
how was I to go back to school work or
even think about college
investigations are dangerous loopholes
saying that the court is going to
mandate an investigation before allowing
a marriage
puts the minor at even more risk she has
been manipulated and coerced for weeks
before the marriage to say yes
there is no way that a minor child is
going to stand up against their parents
or a caseworker and say look I'm being
forced to do this I'm being coerced
children are peacemakers and they're
going to keep the peace just as I did
I believe that we have evolved as a
nation and that our laws need to do the
same
teen marriage is a thing of the past and
yes lots of our parents grandparents and
ancestors married young
we're a different Nation now I think we
can agree that we want our children to
have the same opportunities as we did or
as most of us have and that is to live
to their fullest potential
emancipation is not going to save this
as I said my marriage was considered an
automatic emancipation And yet when I
want it out or needed a lawyer or wanted
to enroll in school
I was I was helpless
going back to the military that we were
talking about earlier my second husband
was a career active duty in the Army and
then Coast Guard and retired as a Navy
officer recruiter
two of my sons joined the military one
in the National Guard and one in the
Navy
they both signed contracts at 17 years
old and that contract was a promise not
a legal binding contract so in fact even
though they signed it and promised that
they would join at 18 years old they
could have backed out if they wanted to
I submitted a written testimony for
myself and that of another child
marriage Survivor and I thank you to the
representatives that responded to those
um
the 17 year old that I was allowed to
interview
wished that there were Protections in
place to prevent her from marrying
they didn't want to marry but were told
that it was in their best interest to
marry
they believed that had they not married
and had they stayed home there's we're
just talking about four or five months
before they turned 18.
they believed that they would have
graduated from high school felt
empowered and said no to the marriage
thank you for your time
thank you very much are there any
questions for Miss Tyree
seeing none thank you very much
next up is Casey Reagan
I was just on
CE
she's not an assist oh oh there she is
hi
so um my name is Casey Reagan I'm 17
years old and I live in North Haverhill
New Hampshire where I attend Woodsville
high school I'm also a member of the
legislative youth advisory Council and
though I'm not representing them today
at the moment we are planning on
releasing a statement as it pertains to
this Bill I'm here to testify in support
of hb60 and act relative to raising the
minimum age of marriage I've been
following this issue and representative
levesque's work on it for quite some
time and so I'm super excited to be here
today to hear the discussion and to add
my two cents
I'm going to be graduating high school
in a couple of months and heading off to
college and I'm so blessed to be in a
situation where I can do that where I've
been financially and emotionally
supported and now I can take the next
step in my life
most victims of child marriage aren't so
lucky as we've already discussed women
who marry as minors are 50 more likely
to drop out of high school and those who
do go to college are four times less
likely to finish this leaves them with a
lack of opportunities for growth in
their careers making them financially
dependent on their husbands especially
when there are children involved this
makes it harder for them to escape when
they are faced with abuse at the hands
of their spouse and unfortunately abuse
rates are high in child marriages
women who married under the age of 18
are three times more likely to be abused
than women who aren't this fact should
be even more concerning considering the
uptick in reports of domestic violence
during the pandemic
a common argument for child marriage is
teen pregnancy supporters want teens to
be able to get married as if marriage
somehow is a solution and that's an
argument within itself but regardless
the statistics show that marriage as a
result of teen pregnancy does more harm
than good
teen mothers who marry are even less
likely to go to college than those those
who don't and teen mothers who marry
before or within two years of the birth
of their first child are more likely to
have a second child within that two-year
interval if we really wanted to do
something about teen pregnancy maybe
it's time we take another look at our
state's sex ed guidelines which haven't
been updated last I checked since 2003.
and sex ed isn't required in the state
outside of learning about STIs and HIV
if we wanted to take another look into
the issue of teen pregnancy I think
that's a better way to start and as for
supporting teen mothers maybe we should
invest more into programs that actually
support their needs like lowering the
cost of education and child care and
paid family leave
as I said I'm 17 years old and I wanted
to testify today because in the state of
New Hampshire I'm legally allowed to
marry with my parents permission I
flattened myself to say that I'm a
pretty responsible kid I don't drink I
do my chores study hard and keep my nose
clean
but I'm just a kid three weeks ago I
almost burned down my house making
waffles
I don't even know how to schedule my own
doctor's appointments let alone how to
be a wife no one by age does to say that
16 and 17 year olds aren't mature enough
to enter into the commitment that is
marriage is ludicrous at best and
dangerous at worst
don't you remember what it was like to
be 17 don't remember how young you were
then and how little you knew and how
much you've learned since
one of the reasons I'm so passionate
about this issue is because when I hear
these statistics I don't just hear
numbers I see my friends I see how
excited we are to be starting our lives
to be planning our next few years at
college
I think of the girls I know who are
getting their first car their first kiss
who are pulling all-nighters to finish
their chem homework and scraping by on
three hours of sleep in an ungodly
amount of iced coffee
I think of them and it makes me want to
cry to think of them being put into a
situation where they get married within
the next year
we are so young we don't know anything
we don't know what we want to do with
our lives most of us haven't even had
our first boyfriends yet we're not ready
to be wives and if there are teens out
there who think that they're ready to
settle down with the love of their life
before the age of 18. at most this bill
would only be an inconvenience
this bill is about giving girls every
chance at life we deserve to grow up to
find ourselves young people girls and
guys shouldn't be getting married before
the age of 18. I can see no good
arguments as to why we should keep this
practice alive in our state and so I
hope you join me in supporting hb60
thank you for your time and um I'm happy
to answer for questions if you have any
thank you very much are there any um
questions from Miss Reagan
seeing none thank you very much for your
testimony thank you
and up next is Amanda Parker
hi this is Amanda Parker can you hear me
now yeah yeah
thank you so much chair rice and and for
the distinguished committee members for
prioritizing a hearing on this important
legislation and to representative
Levesque for her unrelenting leadership
on this issue over the years I'm Amanda
Parker I'm the senior director for the
AHA Foundation
at the AHA Foundation we work to end
harmful practices including forced
marriage child marriage and female
genital mutilation in the U.S including
supporting survivors and at-risk
individuals find safety and services
we were founded by ion here CLE who
herself is a survivor of forced marriage
and female genital mutilation
I'm here today to record our strong
support for hb60 which would end all
child marriage in the state without
exceptions
I want to talk specifically today about
the loopholes that allow for 16 and 17
year olds to marry
the first is the parental consent
loophole which dates back to 1907 and
which is also absurd
in aha foundation's experience when a
child is forced to marry the
perpetrators are almost always the
parents so parental consent is often
parental coercion
children can easily be forced or coerced
into marriage or trapped into abusive
marriages
miners being forced or coerced into
marriage may feel fear familial violence
should they refuse to comply or they may
be physically or emotionally manipulated
into accepting unwanted marriages
minors may also not have the resources
to find a way out of the situation
they face significant legal and
practical barriers if they try to leave
home enter a domestic violence shelter
retain an attorney get a credit card or
file a legal action such as divorce
this is why the AHA Foundation started
working to fight child marriage in the
U.S it's because we had minors coming to
us trying to seek escape from a forced
marriage and we were unable to use those
normal tools that we would have
available to us if we were working with
an adult
the judicial review process is also
deeply flawed
a judge is allowed but not required to
interview a 16 or 17 year old who seeks
permission to marry without their
parents present
now even if a judge opts to conduct such
an interview that does little to prevent
a forced marriage and in fact introduces
additional trauma to an already
traumatic situation
it puts the onus on a terrified 16 or 17
year old who is being forced to marry to
choose between telling the truth and
facing the repercussions back at home or
lying to the court
whether or not the parents Guardians and
or the intended spouses are in the room
when the interview is occurring the 16
or 17 year old knows that the family is
going to figure out what happened during
the interview based on the outcome
we have never heard of a single Survivor
going through a judicial review process
when they were being forced to marry
whoever chose to be honest with the
court whether or not they were alone
during the court interview
a judgment must conclude also that the
marriage is in the best interest of the
child as we've heard
as we've also heard the U.S state
department has called marriage before 18
human rights abuse and we've also heard
about the the numerous harms that are
associated with child abuse or with a
child marriage right here in the United
States
now how can something that that we've
deemed to be a human rights abuse ever
be something that's deemed to be in the
best interest of a child
it can't
judges are prohibited from approving a
marriage between parties with an age
difference that constitutes statutory
rape this is pretty much pointless
though because the age of consent is 16
and 16 year olds are no longer allowed
to marry in New Hampshire
yeah
the law also requires the marriage
petition to indicate whether the Bureau
of child protection has been involved
with the child's family however it does
not indicate what the judge should do
with such information
now the solution is not to strengthen
this judicial review process by adding
more so-called safeguards
even the most robust judicial review
process has a fatal flaw as I said it
puts the onus on children to find a safe
way to communicate to a judge that they
are being forced into marriage
this only causes further trauma in an
already traumatic situation
children are facing a horrible decision
when they face that situation being
honest with the court or lying and
feeling complicit in their own forced
marriage
the parental consent and judicial review
process is effectively disempower
children allowing adults to enter
children into marriage and providing
little or no recourse for children who
do not who do not want to marry
as you've heard today child marriage
severely limits opportunities to health
education and economic freedom it also
increases the risk of domestic violence
and it almost always ends in divorce
given these factors one case of forced
marriage is one too many I urge each of
you to favor vote to vote favorably to
advance hb60 without delay and I am so
grateful for your time and I also
welcome any questions
great thank you so much are there any
questions
for Miss Parker
being none thank you very much for your
testimony
and up next we have Giovanna Ortiz
Barrera I hope I said that right
hi yes this is Javan Ortiz yeah
can you all hear me
thank you okay wonderful thank you
um again yes I want to Echo some of my
peers and thanking you all I've been
hearing us out today
uh dear chair rice Vice chair to Simone
and distinguished committee members on
behalf of Unicef USA
I am testifying in support of House Bill
60 sponsored by representative Cassandra
lebeth to make 18 years old the minimum
age of marriage in the state of New
Hampshire with no exceptions as a New
England Community engagement associate
here at UNICEF USA I am constantly
reminded how important it is that
children have the right to be children
too many children lose that right for
too many reasons one of those reasons is
child marriage worldwide more than 650
million women and girls alive today were
married before their 18th birthday some
of them are right here in the United
States in fact an estimated 248
000 children as young as 12 were married
in the United States from 2000 to 2010.
here in New Hampshire between 2000 and
202 children were married as young as
14. UNICEF calls child marriage a
harmful practice and a violation of
child rights and believes that marriage
under the age of 18 should be prohibited
in all circumstances the elimination of
child marriage is included in
sustainable development goal 5 which is
working to achieve gender equality and
Empower all women and girls the goal
calls for an end to child marriage by
2030. in all cases child marriage has
negative impacts on children it leads to
separation from family and friends a
lack of freedom to interact with peers
and participate in community activities
and decrease opportunities for education
and economic participation
because child marriage often results in
child pregnancy girls married at a young
age face serious health risks teenage
girls are much more likely to die in
pregnancy and childbirth than women in
their 20s in addition
childhood pregnancy increases risks of
nutritional deficiencies for both mother
and baby with permanent consequences
these risks are just as real for child
marriages in the United States as they
are in developing countries for the sake
of protecting children from abuse and
protecting their Futures we believe
every single U.S state must take steps
to ban child marriage child marriage is
a violation of Human Rights and comes at
a cost Society cannot afford on behalf
of Unicef USA I urge you to take a stand
for child rights and vote Yes on House
Bill 6C thank you all so much for your
time and consideration
thank you very much are there any
questions
being none thank you again for your
testimony thank you
up next is um Michelle panache
good afternoon my name is Michelle
hanash and I'm testifying today in
support of hb60 the bill that would
finally end the shameful practice of
child marriage in New Hampshire
marriage at 16 or 17 is extremely
harmful and dangerous and that is true
even though a child in New Hampshire is
currently emancipated automatically upon
marriage and here's why automatic
emancipation does nothing absolutely
nothing to prevent the forced marriage
because the minor facing the forced
marriage is not yet emancipated
so a child must first undergo the trauma
of the forced marriage which means being
raped on the wedding night and often
means being pulled out of school before
she gets the right to escape you cannot
unrape a child by later emancipating her
the state of New Hampshire and issuing
that marriage license is a party to the
subjugation of that minor for example
miners cannot easily Escape an impending
forced marriage just by leaving home and
domestic violence shelters will not take
in children under the age of 18. and
youth shelters are required to alert
that Minor's parents within 72 hours and
as you heard minors often are not
allowed to rent a hotel room and is
nearly impossible for a minor to obtain
legal Health as contracts with children
including retainer agreements with
attorneys are avoidable and only the
most generous attorney would agree to
represent a child it is also difficult
for a child to obtain a protective order
against parents forcing her to marry
typically children in New Hampshire
cannot even initiate illegal proceeding
or obtain a protective order without the
assistance from a parent guardian or
next friend and the 83 percent of
children marrying in New Hampshire who
are girls marrying adult men face all
these hurdles while their adult spouses
have no such handicaps
also since the court does not issue an
order of limited emancipation with
automatic emancipation upon marriage as
it typically would in an emancipation
proceedings it is entirely unclear
whether a child married has the right to
file for divorce or seek a protective
order against an abusive spouse or even
leave home to escape an abusive spouse
or unhappy marriage furthermore
automatic emancipation is very dangerous
it likely ends the parents financial
obligation without even evaluating the
child's Financial or emotional
Independence or educational needs in
other cases minors cannot be emancipated
unless they first show they have lived
separately from their parents or legal
Guardians for at least three months can
financially support themselves and have
obtained or pursuing a high school
diploma or an equivalent certificate the
court looks at none of this when it
automatically emancipates a minor just
because they are married and as you
heard as child marriage likely ends in
divorce the child can then be abandoned
and ill-equipped to support herself or
the children she is likely to now have a
child automatically emancipated through
marriage and divorce before 18 may end
up homeless if her parents refuse to
allow her back home
additionally already emancipated
children should not be allowed to marry
New Hampshire's emancipation statute
allows children to petition the court
for an order granting limited
emancipation to the youth however such
emancipation is intended to help
children who cannot be reunited with
their parents by giving them some
limited rights of adulthood such as
living independently managing their
financial affairs and entering contracts
it is unclear what other of any limited
rights of adulthood are conferred like
being able to file a protective order or
having the ability to navigate a
contract as serious as marriage
as stated domestic violence shelters
typically also do not accept anyone
under the age of 18 and it's unclear how
emancipation would affect that rule and
imagine how a landlord might feel about
renting an apartment to a 16 or 17 year
old even one who is emancipated and
legally allowed to rent the apartment
the law specifies also that an
emancipated minor does not have the
right to violate certain health and
safety regulations relevant to the minor
because of the miners age such as using
or possessing tobacco or alcohol
possessing firearms or gambling given
the serious risks to child's health and
safety that marriage poses which is an
increase in the likelihood of a myriad
of physical and mental health problems
as well as increased risk of living in
poverty and being beaten The Logical
conclusion is that children also should
not have the ability to be married
marriage before 18 brings devastating
lifelong consequences for girls the many
repercussions of child marriage do not
disappear if we stamp emancipated on a
girl's forehead emancipated or not
marriage at 16 or 17 is too dangerous
and a child can wait to marry just as
they would enter into any other contract
and I urge each of you to advance hb60
and vote Yes for those reasons thank you
thank you very much are there any
questions
good seeing them thank you very much for
your testimony
up next is
um Sophia
Pandora
I'm so sorry
okay okay
there she is
she's right over here he's here
there we go Sofia there you go hi can
you hear me yes
all right uh thank you madam chair and
members of the committee for taking my
testimony today my name is Sophia biando
Lilo I'm 14. I live in Manchester and
I'm speaking today on behalf of the New
Hampshire High School Democrats in
support of hb60
I'm in support of this bill because the
marriage age in New Hampshire has been
dangerously low for far too long
I remember when the marriage age was 13.
I remember thinking that it was absurd
that I a child who could barely even
manage getting my homework done could
make that sort of commitment to another
person
and the fact is that keeping the
marriage age as low as it is is
dangerous for Youth and is rooted in
Traditions that should be long varied
first of all most children who are at
this stage in their life don't have a
lot of experience with this type of
reasoning or decision making
according to Stanford Children's Health
kids in their early adolescent
development are just beginning to
develop personal decision making skills
and think about the future
and this pivotal stage in their
development I don't think it's
reasonable or fair to put this type of
decision in their hands after all if a
16 year old can't be trusted to drive a
car drink alcohol Vote or buy a house
why should they be able to get married
marriage is also a somewhat permanent
decision that can have long-term effects
on the health of the person getting
married according to the international
Council of Defense of research on women
sorry International Council of research
on women
those who are married in their teen
years are at a much higher risk of
becoming victims of domestic abuse and
sexual assault the quality now which is
an organization dedicated to ending
gender inequality and human trafficking
says the girls married girls married as
teens have higher risk for PTSD
depression and certain heart conditions
as well so not only is this decision one
that many minors aren't ready to make
it's something that could affect them
longer to their adult lives
finally the idea of child marriage is
rooted in misogyny and hundreds of years
of abuse in the past Marion young was
often done out of a perceived economic
necessity this meant that a majority of
child marriages affected immigrants and
to this day most of the teens who get
married in America are undereducated or
impoverished this so-called tradition
needs to be abolished and New Hampshire
needs to step forward and protect the
youth in our state
in conclusion I urge the committee to
support this bill in order to protect
those most vulnerable in New Hampshire
and treat our children with the respect
they deserve
thank you very much are there any
questions for Sophia
great seeing them thank you very much
for your testimony
up next is um Ella pandaya
is not useless
so we will go to
Sarah's name
hi everybody
um can you hear me
I'm sorry yes okay thank you so much
um dear committee members my name is
Sarah Tas neem and I'm here to give my
testimony in support of house bill 60.
um thank you for bringing this bill
forward I think it's so important uh my
name is Sarah tosnim again and I'm a
Survivor of horse child marriage I'm
also a vocal National Advocate to end
child marriage in the United States
because of the horrors I had to endure
as a child with absolutely no Escape
legal or otherwise I hope that no other
child must go through what I did and
that is why I support hv60 I was forced
into a marriage at 15 while visiting my
father in California
I was living with my mom at the time and
she didn't know what was going on
um I was I was introduced to a man that
morning who was 13 years older than me
that night that man became my husband in
a forced spiritual ceremony
six months later after being impregnated
I was forced to legally marry him and it
took me eight long years of overcoming
enormous obstacles including physical
abuse sexual abuse PTSD anxiety being
taken out of school as a 15 year old and
facing extreme poverty to be able to
leave this man
um
I'm sorry
I am not the exception
I am actually the majority of miners who
marry we are three times more likely to
be abused in our marriages
um where
we're much more likely to be pulled out
of school and face extreme poverty later
on
we are
at risk of having lifelong repercussions
that we have to face throughout our
lives
as a 15 year old I became pregnant right
away I had two more children and I was
left with the responsibility of caring
for my kids after eight long years of
fine of finally getting out of that
marriage
it's taken me years to recover from the
abuse and it's taken me years to get
back to where my peers are as far as
education and finances I just recently
graduated with a master's in 2019 that
said most most of my peers
um are just starting their families and
already have their careers ahead of them
I am here
um to really say that um on behalf of
myself and for the people who can't be
here to testify
um I would urge you all to pass this
bill because I can't think of any reason
why New Hampshire would want to continue
these harms and expose minors to a human
rights abuse and um with that I I really
appreciate all of you and all of your
time thank you so much
very much for your testimony are there
any questions
being none thank you very much
up next
Elizabeth
yeah
thank you madam chair and members of the
committee for the record my name is
Elizabeth Satan and I am a child
marriage Survivor
it is my life's work to end this
practice
I was 16 when I was forced to marry
while living in a cult in California
and I need to give you a little bit of
context around this
I was my parents um that it's all
relevant to the story so I just want to
tell you just a little bit about me my
parents divorced at five and my mother
remarried a man who started a cult
and it had a culture of
celibacy
um of people
marrying dominance over people
and I was adopted by my stepfather when
I was 11 so my father lost all legal
rights to me and he was unable to
protect me
I was pulled out of school in eighth
grade
and at 16 I fell in love with an 18 year
old
and
they did not approve of that because it
was a secret relationship although I
remained a virgin throughout
I was
basically stripped
in front this is just the punishment
that they gave me I was confined to my
room I was brought to community meetings
where I was stripped to my underwear
with children watching
I was made an example of
I was shunned and ultimately I was
forced to get married
and otherwise I would have been an
outcast there I couldn't run away I was
a child
and at 16
I was forced to marry a 28 year old
after an engagement of three days
there were no questions by the clerk
there was no judge
and then I was taken to the South
Pacific for two and a half years
they took my passport
it was statutory rape
I basically lost consent over my body I
lost consent over my life
my dad was told after the wedding that I
was married
and this man was obsessed with sex
on the 4th of July 1984 when I was 19
years old
he showed some weakness about his being
um
basically being
committed to the cult and I seized on
this and I called his mother who lived
in a nearby City and asked her if she
could help us and she delivered a car
with the key on the tire
I escaped that evening and with him and
I went to see my father who I hadn't
seen in 12 years
the aftermath for me is I still have
nightmares I'm 53 years old
I have mental health issues I've been
through a lot of therapy I'm still in
therapy
I'm a mother of a 16 year old that's the
age that I was married off
she still likes stuffed animals
she's only been on one date and it was a
picnic
I'm sorry it's emotional for me
in the state of California you can't tan
until you're 18.
in a tanning booth
just a little relevance
this is not about religious freedom
it's a child protection issue
as you can see
the doors just kept closing for me I was
adopted I was married my passport was
taken away I would have been a runaway
if and I would have been returned to my
parents I had no options
women in distress get help
children in distress married do not
my story is actually a story of
resilience I became an international
model at the age of 20.
I got my master's degree
and I have a thriving career in health
care
I am not
the average child marriage Survivor
thank you for considering hb60 I urge
you to vote for it
thank you very much for your testimony
are there any questions
staying done thank you very much
next is oh yeah Abbas
um yes hi hi
good afternoon chair rice Vice chair de
Simone and distinguished committee
members my name is Aaliyah Abbas and I
am a child marriage Survivor and an
activist who will continue to fight
until
my whole country is free of child
marriage as a child marriage Survivor I
request you to vote Yes on bill hb60
because it simply will put an end to
child marriage voting yes would mean
eliminating the abuse of placing
children in the most vulnerable hopeless
and abusive
and excuse me abusive situations it is a
fact that parental consent is most often
parental coercion as was in my case
um even though in this state
um the marriage age is 18 but the law
still permits 16 and 17 year olds to
marry with parental consent and
Judiciary approval and like I said in
most cases parental consent is Parental
coercion
the U.S state department has has called
marriage below 18 a human rights abuse
and a human rights abuse is never in the
best interest of a child even a more
robust judicial review process would be
dangerous it would put the child being
forced to marry in the most terrifying
position of choosing between being
honest with the court or facing the
consequences at home
um or lying to the court and I if I were
um to be put into that situation with
the type of family that I grew up in I
would be forced to lie
um 17 year olds are at the highest risk
of being forced into marriage because
they are close to graduating from high
school which is often when parents
um worry that children will become too
independent and will choose to marry
them off I can I can attest to it being
that 17 year old child bride 18 years
ago child marriage destroys girls health
education and economic opportunities and
increases their risk of experiencing
further violence and Trauma between 2000
and 2017 nearly 88 of child marriages
were were of children aged 16 and 17. so
what does life look like for children
who are who are forced into this abuse
to start off with the children who are
forced um
uh to to to endure this lifetime trauma
of the forced marriage are are also
likely to be pulled out of school
um just as I was we know how important
education is for children especially
girls child brides are physically
mentally and emotionally abused
um and manipulated
uh also raped before they could gain the
rights they need to escape at 18.
um children child marriage excuse me
puts the health and well-being and
safety of children into Jeopardy 70 to
80 percent of marriages before 18 and in
Failure which puts children in such
situations at risk of uh homelessness
because they lack the financial
Independence so what would we be really
doing here other than putting the lives
of these children at risks
um to all sorts of uh Danger
I wholeheartedly support this bill
because it hits home it's extremely
personal I am a product of child
marriage and who better than a child
bride to know the reality of this
Injustice at 17 years old in January of
2003 my senior year I was taken out of
school in Maryland which is my home
state and I was flown to a foreign
country where I was forced
um to marry a man who was 25 years old
at that time who was a complete stranger
within three weeks of being in that in
that country all without my consent
that one instance changed my life
forever the first night of my marriage I
was raped I became a teenage mother
um without my consent to my two children
I had a DNC before that and when I was
at the hospital
um getting my DNC because the baby had
had uh had lost its uh heartbeat
my ex my ex husband who was who's still
a stranger
um was in Dubai and he was enjoying and
he and he was partying
um being a mother is one of the most
fulfilling jobs I have but I will not
lie it took every ounce of my being to
get to where I am
um today and it stick and it still takes
a toll I
I I
can't even I can't even describe to you
how much it took for me to when I came
back here
um three months after my marriage how
hard it was for me to graduate high
school but I still did it
um I
I still held on to hope and to Faith and
to God and I moved forward I was
pregnant and I went to college
I was you know I had my infant my first
child and I took my child to college
with me I went to work with my children
when the daycare would not accept them I
was you know then I took both of my
children to my classes with me night
classes so yes I went through college I
put myself through college but I took
every ounce of me and I was only a child
raising two children by myself I cannot
describe to you the feeling
and the hardships that I went through
um
and a lot of child rides it's a fact
that they do not go through college they
do not they do not get to finish High
School I don't know what it was but I
kept pushing and I did not want to
become that I did not want to become
part of the uh statistics
but I I'm telling you I still don't know
how I did it today
and the marriage was you know full of
abuse and when um I I totally forgot the
name of the gentleman who spoke before
when he talked about uh ownership I am a
very strong strong woman I'm gonna say
that I do not let anybody own me the
only person who owns me is me but
my ex ex-husband who was 25 years old
thought that he did own me
I fought back
and the consequences was more meetings
more torture more rape more physical
abuse more mental abuse you know
um so while we may not think that hey
nobody owns us the the abuser does think
that they do
I wouldn't wish this experience for
anyone I was bullied I was beaten I was
raped I would just like to say one thing
that I never Define myself as a victim
even though I have been been brutally
victimized I'm a Survivor who had the
courage to finally stand up for myself
and most importantly for the sake of my
children at any cost even when the cost
was death as per my uncle because when
we spoke about divorce my uncle said hey
the women in our culture which is which
is the Muslim Pakistani American culture
um women are not they're they're not
allowed to get divorced but I still took
the step knowing that I was going to
risk death I took the step and I you
know got myself out of it
um that that is not the reality for a
lot of girls who stay Within These
marriages
um
I didn't know how to swim in a ocean of
uncertainty but I took a huge risk
toward my freedom and my children's
freedom I taught myself how to swim with
that uncertainty
um and it's still it's still a process
it's a lifetime of healing it's a
lifetime of trauma
unfortunately most child Brides do not
get
um do not get the opportunity to get out
of this situation and they abuse they
experience a lifetime of abuse in all
forms of dehumanization torture
um all types of abuse and sadly uh even
death in some cases hb60 will simply
will simply and child marriage and that
is what we need to do we need to step up
and protect our children our girls thank
you so much for giving me this
opportunity to speak and I would just
like to say I do have a speech
impediment
um and I did not let that get get in the
way today
thank you so much
are there any um questions
right saying John thank you very much
for your testimony
you're so welcome
next we have
um Freddy rice or Reese
hi uh can you hear me yep there you go
oh great
um all right well chair rice and
distinguished committee members uh thank
you for this time I am Frady Reese I'm
the founder and executive director of
Unchained at last which works to end
force and child marriage in the U.S and
I am testifying today as both a forced
marriage Survivor and an expert whose
research and writing on force and child
marriage have been published widely I
urge you to vote Yes on hb60 and end
child marriage in New Hampshire and I
want to give a a special thank you to
representative Levesque who refuses to
give up and it was going to keep coming
back as will we until New Hampshire ends
child marriage
uh you've heard some powerful testimony
today on all the reasons that we need to
end child marriage the harms and dangers
of marriage including at 16 and 17 the
reasons the current law
um is not sufficient the reasons that it
should be 18 no exceptions when it comes
to marriage uh I want to touch on an
issue it's a question that comes up a
lot we had Unchained have spoken with
many of you individually and a question
that comes up a lot is what if a girl is
pregnant isn't she better off getting
married shouldn't she get married and so
I just want to talk about that please
I want to be clear that there are only
six U.S states that still allow a
pregnancy to the marriage Aid a
pregnancy exception to the marriage age
because what uh what legislative have
legislators have realized is that
marrying off pregnant teenage girls is
terrible public policy and states have
moved away from this in in fact most
recently South Carolina and Ohio just in
2019 Florida and Kentucky in 2018
um have moved away from the pregnancy
exceptions in their marriage age laws
and several states have passed
legislation specifying that pregnancy is
not enough of a reason to approve a
child marriage and here's why two main
reasons first of all policy makers used
to believe that a pregnant teenage girl
was better off getting married and it
turns out studies show that pregnant
teenage girls who stay single actually
have better long-term outcomes than
pregnant teenage girls who marry
for example married teenage mothers in
the United States are 40 more likely
than unmarried teens to give birth to a
second baby within 24 months
teen mothers who marry while they're
pregnant are less likely ever to return
to school than teen mothers who do not
marry and that's really significant
because we already know how uh how
significant the child how significantly
child marriage impacts
um education you heard some of those
statistics earlier and also teenage
mothers in the United States who marry
and then divorce are more likely to
suffer economic deprivation and
instability than teenage mothers who
stay single and you heard again
repeatedly today that those who marry as
children are almost guaranteed to
divorce 70 to 80 percent of marriages
before 18 end in divorce
there are other really important reason
that pregnancy that allowing uh pregnant
girls to marry or Marigold pregnant
goals is is terrible public policy is
that pregnancy exceptions of marriage
age have been used to cover up rape and
to force girls to marry their rapists
you heard from several survivors today
who talked about their experience uh
being forced to marry their rapists and
this is something that we had Unchained
we provide Direct Services and we have
seen this repeatedly is marriage used to
cover up rape and to force girls to
marry their rapists uh pregnant teenage
girls are at an increased risk of forced
marriage this is what we have seen again
and again and if a girl gets pregnant
and she is from a family or community
that views unwed motherhood as shameful
she is at a significantly increased risk
of a forced child marriage possibly to
her own rapist a girl like that needs
more protection not less protection and
I also want to make clear there's always
a question that comes up about
co-parenting well you know let's say
they want to start a family and a girl
is having a baby and wants that
co-parent well guess what the father of
a baby who wants a co-parent can easily
do that outside of marriage all he has
to do is establish paternity New
Hampshire makes it extremely easy like
Most states to establish paternity and
that way the baby would be covered under
the father's health insurance and other
benefits and a teenage girl could easily
co-parent without being entered into
this serious contract of marriage with
all the harms that it brings and and you
heard also how difficult it is for her
to get out of that if she doesn't want
it and also if the father does not want
to co-parent the mother could still uh
does not need a marriage license to get
relief she could still petition the
court to establish paternity and to
enforce his basic obligation of support
New Hampshire law provides for that and
besides think about how terrible the
outcome would be if there's an you try
to force an unwilling father to
co-parent by forcing him into uh into a
marriage
also be very clear that the federal
government and Most states no longer
refer to a child born out of wedlock as
illegitimate or treat such children
differently and indeed New Hampshire law
states that if father's obligations are
identical whether the child was born of
unwed parents or in wedlock New
Hampshire law already establishes that
and think about it also if you want to
make sure that no child is born
so-called out of wedlock then we would
have to set the marriage age at the
earliest age of puberty which is
approximately eight and could be even
younger and I think we can all agree
that setting the marriage age at eight
is not what we want to see
and so I um I just once again urge you
to vote Yes on hb60 and end child
marriage 18 no exceptions just it
doesn't matter if there is a pregnancy
or not thank you
thank you very much are there any
questions
see none thank you once again for your
testimony
so that's all I have on my list and
there is one hand raised yeah I'm
getting there
um uh
tomorrow
I'm sorry
um I'm sorry I know I just butchered
that
there we go
now sorry about that
yeah
um can you hear me yes oh cool
um so yeah my name is Asma elohini and I
was
um married at 16 years old as well
um I was no way at an age able to grow
into an independent person at 16
nonetheless have a family
um I did drop out of high school
um I married someone who was 12 years
older than me it was a relationship that
included control manipulation and abuse
um I also got pregnant at 16 a child
myself
um and I got married in the state of New
Jersey
a long story short my marriage did wind
up in a divorce
um and I also just want to say that I
disagree with the fact that this is
always parent coercion my parents didn't
coerce me I actually fell in love with a
man that I Thought I Loved uh though my
parents didn't want to let the marriage
happen at such a young age I would have
still ran away with him if they didn't
agree to it so I just want to
acknowledge that and also I want to
acknowledge that parent coercion does
happen and that's important to point
that out I also want to point out the
response to one speaker saying that any
relationship under 18 is manipulative
it's important that we don't label
people under 18 automatically in a
manipulative relationship because people
are going out with each other Who are 16
and 17 years of age are all people under
18 in a manipulative relationship no
um but at the same time I think that if
people are in love at such a young age
below 18 they should just wait until
they both are 18 before making the
decision to get a legal marriage so I
support this bill hb60 because the
possibility of coercion from parents
sometimes is possible it doesn't allow
girls to grow into themselves because
they're too busy taking care of families
and for me my divorce like I had to go
back to college and I only graduated
four years ago I am 44 years old now
um so please do pass this bill because
it wasn't easy going back to school and
getting my life back on track and to
also set the record straight I am a
Muslim woman unfortunately someone said
Muslim women can't get divorced which is
false information but what is true is
that some interpretations of the
religion make it so that some make it
hard for women to be able to get a
divorce but I needed to clarify that
because I don't want my religion to be
continuously stereotyped toxic
patriarchal practices happen in all
cultures all religions all countries and
so we need to work together to stop that
so please do support this bill and pass
it for our community's sake thank you
thank you very much are there any
questions
being none
thank you very much
we have one more person Vivian Hamilton
thank you very much chair rice and
honorable committee members I'm Vivian
Hamilton I'm a professor of law at
William and Mary School of Law and I
direct the William and Mary Center for
racial and social justice
I teach courses at Family Law education
law race in the law and federal civil
procedure I speak today in support of
hb60 to allow only adults aged 18 and
over to Mary
I do not consider myself an activist
instead I research how legal measures
across a range of contexts affect
adolescence
most relevant to today's hearing I
published an article on the marriage age
in the 2012 edition of the Boston
University law review
as you've heard in too many cases minors
are coerced into marrying you've heard
that miners particularly girls are
vulnerable to this sort of coercion
either by their prospective spouses or
by a girl's own parents
the importance of protecting children
from the lifelong harms imposed by this
sort of coercion is almost too planned
for words
I'm focusing today however on the high
social cost of early marriage even when
entered voluntarily as the last speaker
noted and I'll try not to belabor some
of the statistics that other speakers
have shared with you
um but as you as you've heard women who
marry in their teens are more likely to
drop out of high school less likely to
finish college than those who delay
marriage more likely to live in poverty
than those who delay marriage uh Team
mothers who marry between conception and
childbirth are less likely to ever
return to school than those who delay
marriage I'd also like to emphasize for
you that they are more likely to have a
rapid second birth than teen mothers who
don't marry they're also more likely to
have more children overall both closely
spaced births and having two or more
children are associated with lower
educational attainment
uh there are other social costs
including psychological costs a study
reported by the New York Times found
that teen marriage was significantly
associated with mental disorders for
women particularly major depressive
disorder it also correlates with worse
physical health for women putting them
at greater risk of heart attack diabetes
cancer and stroke
now to quote the national marriage
project
quote agent marriage is the strongest
and most consistent predictor of marital
stability ever found by social science
research end quote so we're all probably
familiar with the statistic that nearly
half of all U.S marriages end in divorce
when we break that statistic down
however we see consistently and over
decades the following for individuals
who delay marrying into their mid-20s
fewer than 30 percent will divorce when
individuals marry before 18 as happens
in New Hampshire nearly 70 percent will
divorce when children married at age 16
as happens in New Hampshire nearly 80
percent will divorce I want to emphasize
as well that these rates of marital
failure hold even when parents consent
to minors marriages and they hold even
when judges consent
delaying marriage by even a single year
on the other hand significantly reduces
the odds of divorce
you might be wondering after all of this
testimony why are the marriages of the
young so unstable
it's a complex uh issue but it seems to
roughly boil down according to research
to two factors the first is economic
into the mid 20th century a young person
didn't need to graduate high school in
order to obtain a blue-collar job that
paid a wage sufficient to support a
family
to earn a wage sufficient to support a
family in today's economy requires more
years of Education and Training than can
typically be acquired before age 18.
low paying work and occupational
instability hinders the ability to
support a family and financial
insecurity stresses the marital
relationship
the second
factor is relational
the meaning of marriage has evolved over
the centuries and decades today Mary
Carey marriage carries greater symbolic
and personal value than ever
we expect of our spouses a degree of
relational intimacy and connection are
greater than in the past
today we no longer just expect a good
provider For Better or For Worse we now
expect a soul mate
as a result
today's marriages require mature
relational capacities and these depend
on a level of Psychosocial maturity that
adolescents lack
uh finally in closing
um you know we might ask why should we
care that most young people who marry
than divorce because at least some of
those marriages last right
well
this is why we should care
marriage is arguably the primary social
institution in the U.S
um
and in New Hampshire
it's a civil status
what it's created by the state when the
state gives its stamp of approval it's
saying this relationship is good for
these individuals it's good for their
families and it's good for our society
we encourage this
but as you've heard
for these minors marriage is not a good
it overwhelmingly hinders their
well-being their future their ability to
reach their potential and what they are
ultimately able to contribute to society
so underage marriage is also not good
for broader Society
for those reasons
um
I argue and hope that you will agree
that our states should no longer
sanction child marriage thank you so
much for your time
after there any questions
and thank you very much
so I see that there is someone else has
raised their hand in the attendees list
I would ask that any testimony you give
not be
um
an echo of of everything that we've
already heard because we keep hearing
the same testimony so I'm going to crawl
on Rima nashibi
uh thank you thank you chair rice Vice
chair di Simone and other distinguished
reps uh I'm the founder and president of
global hope 365 which is a 501c3
nonprofit organization dedicated to
improving the lives of women and girls
locally and nationally and our goal is
to end harmful practices against women
and girls like child marriage human
trafficking and other types of uh gen
other forms of gender-based violence
domestic violence
I'm not going to repeat anything that
was said before I just want to bring
your attention to one thing
a number of a couple of things a number
of the child marriage survivors
indicated parental consent is Parental
coercion the office of the United
Nations uh on drugs and crime issued a
report recently on the interlinkages
between forced child marriage and human
trafficking which as we all know
involves fraud force and coercion and
benefiting commercially from the use and
abuse of another human being so fraud
force and coercion is included in both
child marriage and human trafficking in
addition the American Medical
Association has passed a resolution and
has called for an end to child marriage
stating child marriage is associated
with higher rates of sexually
transmitted infections infant and
maternal mortality early pregnancies
divorce and intimate partner violence
then compared to women married at the
age of 21. thank you that's all what I
wanted to say because the rest of my
testimony which I emailed is a repeat of
what everything everybody else said
thank you very much
is there any questions
[Music]
and they've seen no more hands raised so
I am going to close the hearings on
House Bill 60.
many members we are going to take about
a five minute break
and then come back and accept two bills
we're going to do um HP 427 and HB 254.
okay
I'm good so um committee members or
cameras will be will have to be on in
order
um to vote during the exact session just
so you know so we'll be back in say 3
40. give this a few more minutes
can you hear me yes thank you
okay
welcome back everyone
um oh we have to wait for the floor hold
on
I can't start without her nope
thank you
okay
so I'm going to oh my God
look why does his mouth make this hand
there is a hand on your shoulder ripped
out shoulder and I was like what's
happening it was the mouse
within the executive session on House
Bill 427.
I'll recognize representative at chiller
to remove
thank you
at 105 this afternoon every member of
the committee received an email which is
a resend of the amendment you got last
week from OLS to House Bill 427
um
and I move the amendment be adopted
and it was seconded by representative
would you like to speak to your motion
uh sure in section if you if you're
looking at the original bill
um section 2A so it would be line seven
in the original bill
will now be that whole section A will be
replaced and
um it actually just adds in
if you look on line five of the
amendment it adds in the words agency
shall include any public or private
entity under contract or agreement with
the Department of Health and Human
Services so the two words or agreement
are the addition and this is a request
um
for a clarification in The Language by
the office of the child advocate
is there any further discussion
representative cross can you turn on
your camera I know you're here but it
because you're on the screen too it
looks like you're not
so we have to take a roll call on a
darkening amendment is that correct
Christina
yes
okay
I will have the um
the clerk called the role on the
adoption they called Amendment
group number 20210149h
I'm here muted for representative Elsia
I'm sorry would you repeat the adoption
number
2021-0149h
thank you
Christina can you hear me
yes I can
okay so the sheet that you just sent me
is different than the one I have so I'm
gonna use the one I have because
a piece of paper in my hand that's fine
okay thank you
all right
um
representative D Simone
representative yokella
yes
representative blue Wiki yes
representative Belanger
yes
representative cross
representative Litchfield
yes
representative Smith
representative long
yes
representative Ali Saya yes
representative Grossman
yes
representative Levesque
representative was there
yes
representative petrigno yes
representative hot ship I'm sorry hot
Schiller
a representative Madam chair rice
yes
15-0
is the vote
the amendment passes
[Music]
it's adopted thank you
I moved the house bill 427 as a as
amended
OTP
so otpa
otpa there you go that too yeah
I'm sorry who said that place so maybe
representative alchiller
I'm very seconded
representative D Simone
yes
representative yokella
representative lewicki yes
representative Belanger
yes
representative cross
representative Litchfield
yes
Representatives
representative
yes
representative long yes
representative Ali Saya yes
representative Grossman
yes
representative levank
foreign
yes
Representative Patrick now yes
representative Paul Schiller yes
15-0
a man share votes yes
Madam chair
representative Bryce
thank you
without objection we can put it on the
consent calendar
yeah that's right yeah
I'm going to give the clerk a minute to
catch up
okay
so if that session is when we vote on
the the bills that we have so uh
we just held the exact session for 4 27
and we're gonna do an exact session for
um 254 and what we do is we make a
recommendation to the house floor so it
would go it will go in the calendar
whoever makes the motion so for example
representative Al Schiller made the
motion ought to pass as amended so
she'll be writing the committee report
not me
I've been trying to like writing
committed reports and that's what and if
it had been
okay say that had been in the majority
vote but but there was a minority
someone else could write a Minority
Report
good versions of it in the calendar
right but because this was unanimous and
it doesn't have a fiscal note it can go
on the consent calendar
the consent calendar is at the beginning
of our calendar at every house session
we take one vote for the entire consent
calendar now if there's a bill on there
that you don't agree with and you want
to pull it off
you can do that ahead of time you have
to let the clerk know and then you can
fight it on the house floor
um but usually you know we'll put it on
consent and it usually stays there
unless there's something you know hugely
unforeseen but so so that's what we're
doing is
um we're voting on these and and I chose
these two today because there really
wasn't a lot of discrepancy in the bills
so
be an easy first time going through so
if there's an amendment we move the
amendment and then someone would
um move on to pass as amended and then
we vote on it and you know but and we'll
have some discussion especially on the
ones that you know we may not all agree
on
so that's what we're doing and I
apologize for not going into detail for
the new people
I hope I did okay did I cover everything
Pat
yeah
okay
all right so
next we're going to
um move on to
the house bill 254.
and I would like to move Amendment
2021-01-40h I'll second that one too
thank you and that was seconded by
representative D Simone
that we
spoke yeah I'm going to get to you
representative yokelo let me speak to my
motion
okay no before you you start talking can
you repeat the the
um number so that we can all look at
what you're talking about when you speak
to the motion
can you repeat that number one
zero one four zero eight
and it was sent to you last week when we
have the public hearing and the people
in here have the hard copies
are you ready to vote Madam chair
no I'm gonna I'm gonna speak to my
motion first okay
so this was the um amendment that we had
talked about that replaced the bill
check out the Care Management entities
in it and just um helps to reduce the um
the amount of kids being sent to the new
center we had done it a few years ago
um at the time I was against that but
it's been very successful we now have
more Community Services out in the
communities the funding has gone out so
um I think it's it's safe to you know
let's keep these kids back in their
communities and um not in a prison
setting you know walk down
so representative yokella did you have
something to say
we're still looking for the amendment so
um I uh you'll have to go on without me
I guess I'll put it in my email
I searched for 254 and it doesn't seem
to be coming up under that
um
I have it right here hold on one second
and I will forward it to you does
anybody else need it
yes if you could send it to the whole
caucus because I don't have it either
right
okay hold on
so I don't know how to do this
just forwarded to CFL children caucus
you know children family law committee
there it is okay thank you
I was freaking out thinking I had to
type in everything
okay I sent it so
it's it's not attached
to smell that
you just forwarded the text but not the
actual thing but I should be able to
search from that language see if I have
it here somewhere oh a word and include
there we go
there you go I'm getting through the
include attachment
did you get it
yes I received it yep
I'm sorry
do you have a question
put your hand down
yeah representative lewicki uh Madam
chair I believe we may not all be
getting all of the emails but I'm gonna
have to if we honor obviously we can't
know it
and so you didn't get it uh no I I can't
know right now whether I did or not but
I believe that there are some that were
mentioned today that I did not get and
so we've got a straight make sure that
that's not happening because obviously
the people will do that yeah so um check
with house Community Services I'll have
them check on that okay thank you okay
hey
representative yokella
no yes
sure all right thank you
I will um
my concern with this uh
uh Amendment
is that it doesn't seem to fully address
the
concerns brought up
as we go from a list of things that
um
are saying like everything except this
can be put into sununu Center and going
to a list of
um
everything but this
is allowed to go to or or only this is
allowed to go to com
um
yes yes the list of only
and there's a there are a number
of
uh
uh crimes that was brought up in
committee that said
that there was concern that some of the
things
um were violent that wouldn't be allowed
to go to to the sununi center and
that the placement options for people
convicted of those crimes
may be limited
um including no option for placement
because
the crime is is
a type of crime that that facility is
has no capability of
um
securely
uh serving that that person you know
whether it be protecting them or
segregating them off from from other
people or whatever the the reason may be
there was some concern
mentioned
uh
about that and I don't feel that it's
been adequately addressed
um one of the things I have I got a list
of some of the bill some of the
potential things that may
cause harm cause
conflict
um and I think that it would be best
that this committee go into kind of a
work session or something like that to
address and make sure that all of these
um
these potential crimes could be serviced
um outside of the sununu center
um and until that has happened I'm not
sure that this change is appropriate
because I don't think that we have
enough information